it's a nightmare a nightmare a
nightmare I sleep when a nightmare yes
guys this is my original song I hope you
guys enjoy it we uh we took some samples
from an artist I'm a big fan of and
turned it into a new
song it's called nightmare by H podcast
it's kind a
fire we're today by pokem man Friends of
the
show
Big Friend big fan big lover of the show
honestly we love having poke man here
it's always fun and you know as a friend
of the show we just we like to enjoy
just doing a regular show and you're the
host I mean that's what I've always
wanted I feel like there there there
aren't that many kinds of content that I
get parasocial with Stephanie Sue is one
of them I love her and your guys'
podcast is one of them too cuz you have
so many voices I'm like I'm there too
I'm there too this is my opinion guys
you want
let's go I do today today we do and
today we shall get it yay today's oh I'm
not wearing one of the new Teddy fresh
things keep intro I forgot something
I'll be right can someone just grab me
something cool from the the ra uh next
week as a new Teddy fresh collection
it's going to be super cool super duper
cool super cool is you know what promise
have I are we in October yet yeah or I
mean November okay November is going to
be action packed I just want to say that
at pack yes by the way no sponsors so
thank you to our members we love love
love you guys we have a monster show
today a monster show my God it's a
monster that's oh true oh it's a green
so cool look at this what is it made out
of it's like fuzzy fabric oh super nice
beautiful oh that's pretty cool that
looks so coasty Zach can you play my
song of nightmare
again I just really like it I think it's
a really beautiful song we did you said
it's a Green Day Green Day Vibes I
really love this song W what is
happening
here oh my God okay for starters
wa these are leevan cookies have you
guys ever heard that let's go W wo W
let's go the original one in New York
was right by our apartment really so we
used to walk by there and we did a few
times but the lines out of that thing so
stupid cookie crazy so I was so excited
that they open one in Larchmont H I was
like I need to bring enough for
everybody so I got like a variety pack
thank you so much I think that's like
$500 a
cookie those things are not I'm not
counting for you guys okay so if you
want to just [__] pass them around and I
can bring them to the to everybody else
after you want to is guys yeah they're
very decadent so eat however much you're
comfortable but you know try try little
pieces whatever those are my favorite
cookies ever really so good if anyone
hasn't tried them I've never tried them
and I'm very excited they're so good
like the most decadent cookies I've ever
had it's like you as a kid would dream
like what's the perfect cookie would be
this is it exactly they go like
crazy what the hell like look at the
thickness on
that those are thick boys boy for you
boy here you guys go take one pass it
they're so good
wow I want to hear reviews out of
everyone afterwards what the hell this
is crazy and I got this for
ELA what we got my mom always taught me
you know like if someone's a mom like
they recent recently had a kid or are
about to like to get them a gift for
them because everybody's always thinking
about the baby but people aren't
thinking enough about the mom that's a
good point pregnancy is not easy
postpartum is not easy so I wanted to
get something for you and by the way
this is our third boy we have literally
everything already Mom that's so nice I
hope you enjoy it what do we have in
here so there's like it's very like
pamper heavy this is me but Theodore is
going to love them like Bath bombs the
candle is called like dead sexy it's
it's very cool like flowery stuff just a
nice kind of pamper Day package oh is
that to put out candle yeah I love those
I think it's called a candle Snuffer or
something yeah something like that
before they're very very bougie you know
get that flame out of here that's a
candle cover I believe wow very nice I
hope you like it very cute like this I'm
glad okay I'm sorry to interrupt we can
you thank you thank you so nice you're
so L
[Applause]
sh hold on I a huge bite of [__]
cooking hell yeah wait do you want one
oh hell yeah I'm waiting for everybody
get to get a bite and then I'll it's
making the r I'll have more than one
so
today we have all kinds of action-packed
shenanigans did you hear about the Beast
this huge Mr Beast expose happening oh
not only did I hear about it I was
listening to the very first Source
Trisha's podcast it were before before
the Tweet was posted before anything I
saw Trisha's the title of her podcast I
said click MH wow T I got to
say she's out there breaking storage for
real yeah Cutting Edge of information I
I respect it especially cuz there was a
bit of a gender tone a little bit
so I'm glad she felt comfortable well
she's calling in today really
mhm you guys are breaking stories let's
go no we're she's calling in today to
talk about it actually she reached out
to me she's really and which was great
because I'm you know I want to talk to
her so she's calling in at
1:30 fun
yeah I love that you guys cover these
kinds of stories cuz I'm always so
intrigued but it's not really a part of
the streamer world to talk about this
stuff not not really to talk about it
but that's the thing you know within all
of us is a little catty [__] so I mean
I thought streamers are a little right
but people don't really like talk about
these kinds of newsic you'll get on and
start talking about it and they'll be
like so when are you playing fortnite or
something you know so this is a good
place to you guys the world of live
stream fails is a
different different world than the one I
live in you know mhm
there's a whole different ecosystem of
drama there that I don't I don't really
get into too that's true it's very Niche
so so Niche yeah that all being said uh
she's calling in at 1:30 then we have
another Jimmy Lee is calling in at 2:30
to discuss something that he's done
something really inappropriate I'll show
it to you guys really fast it here is a
picture Sophia varara varara friend of
the show by the way beautiful posted and
Jimmy left a comment million likes by
golly col cream different flavors you're
my favorite Sophia please reach out we
need to do a collaboration together I'm
a famous comedian on the streets Jimmy
Lee the
street that's a good coffee pasta period
like you're my favorite so I don't know
if this is an inappropriate comment for
a married
man do you know what I mean um it's a
little too like
yeah you know everything else was kind
of okay though you're my favorite
yeah also the context of the picture is
a little the context of the photo yep
yeah
right the context of the photo matters
my
favorite so I got to ask him about that
he's got he's married I mean I think his
wife is entitled to see that you need to
investigate to be honest absolutely hold
it um we've also got my mom's birthday
today she's going to call in you know
what's funny happy
birthday my mom goes okay I'll call in I
have this really nice story about
Abraham and ishmail that really explains
the conflict today I was like [__] no
you are not saying that you have no idea
what imagine holy [__] yeah let's keep
your birthday
happy exactly
exactly the hus
um and then I guess we
have when I listen to the show Zach the
hamus gets me every
time we were thinking of doing oh we
have also David do tea that was the
other thing we have a friend of mine on
um Tik Tok she does like Finance videos
and stuff that I follow and she just out
of the blue dm'd
me this clip of Vlog Squad people mhm
talking about and this is old resurfaced
saying that David could be arrested or
even sued for the things he's done in
the past and they're not kidding really
like it's not even in a joking to no
they're having like a serious
conversation about it and I've got it
right here and I don't seen wait can I
interject course you guys know the
documentary that Casey neistat did about
what happened to that right watch watch
I wanted to watch it but I couldn't find
mhm well he said a preview link and then
what he's told me he's trying to find
someone to buy it but clearly nobody
wants to buy that [__] let me buy it
online like a pay-per-view you know
seriously just post it to your channel
man people want to see it I agree I
agree that's a good ide I'll text him
yeah let him know let him know I tell
him especially sometimes we get live
updates and it's pretty exciting list I
mean people ask us where is it where the
DST documentary at every couple months I
just hop on Google and I'm like where
not nothing
nothing yeah I want the story he kind of
I I feel like Casey kind of bought it in
a way because everybody was talking
about it yeah story broke the hype kind
of died down yeah I mean dav's just like
a uh he's like a
uh what's that I didn't want to ask
Snapchat star now he is he's a snapper
mhm a lot of people are I don't know why
Snapchat is saying so much but yeah I
heard that he's making like no you you
probably don't wish you were because
have you ever heard someone in real life
be like I love this guy on Snapchat like
I don't know I don't know I have
literally never used Snapchat oh I know
I think not since high school not since
high school I'm pretty sure that's just
where people go to like uh try to pick
up underage that's what I talk James
like recently I talked about it with the
gires and I think Olivia you said you
like using it right click it and I watch
like the little
because they have them now on the
homepage but in terms of like using it
um I haven't used it since like high
school or if a boy at a party is's like
do you use Snapchat I'm like no that's
good exactly by the way I we said this
so many times but people still don't
know this is a sticker on all the tags
of Teddy fresh that you see all the
teddy fresh are stickers every time
yeah peace and luck peace and luck so we
got so much to do you're not yeah we
made this song I don't know if you know
if you've heard this we this is a HD
podcast I have how could I not have both
on my own and in the podcast okay good
it's a
nightmare yeah so we just kind of I
can't breathe man I I I use the vocals
from an artist that I know and I kind of
just no it's just because I it's a
transformative work and I call it
nightmare by Ethan Klein
on it right now guys
for and I do copyright that song in case
anybody's watching who's thinking that
they're going to release it as
well I am
laus say
that oh [__] that's got to be the
funniest gag
ever all right so is uh is she is
Rosanna uh I can uh bring her in if you
like one second I'll let them know that
we're ready I just don't want to keep
them
[Music]
waiting you want to start setting it up
a little bit while I get her lined up
sure yeah I mean if they're ready though
just bring them in okay yeah so
um fill me in on the story so Rosanna oh
it's a story really is someone that's
been around and popular on YouTube for
so long I've actually I've cross paed
with her and and her boyfriend a lot of
time mhm we
met we met her at like uh beef sace
birthday and I think I also saw her when
we were in New York maybe I don't know
but she's known for being just like the
sweetest person she has like a baking
she bakes that's her day yeah so I mean
what could you say about
that uh so here
is the post that she just dropped on
Instagram last
night I didn't know
big news this is big news this is big
news so like first of all when I first
read this I was like hold on this has
got to be a joke like like Rosanna
Pansino is doing a Mr Beast exposed all
the things that I can imagine in the
world not on my bingo card
no and so I'm going to read it to you
guys she said uh just to keep context
I've been allowing others to treat me
poorly in private for so many years I'm
fed up I'm going to start standing up
for myself and finding my
voice she nutmeg in that attitude or
whatever putting some vanilla extract in
that
yes so I'm gon to read
it and then uh she's going to call in
she sent me a bunch of clips and stuff
too so going to read it whoa clips of I
have secret
clips that she filmed while during the
her camera
BTS there's a wait do we have the code
of conduct thing that they sent they
also sent me that I don't know if you
sent me that I just videos hold on let
me for you this sure not read it
everyone had to sign this code of
conduct saying like there's rules about
the game you can't do okay and you're
not allowed to film and stuff so but her
camera died and they told her just
record on your phone okay what rules
then at the end of the day they're like
just hang on to it and send us on the
weekend cuz everyone's tired and that's
why she has it but she's got um tons of
Clips there that are corroborating her
story here is the the rules and regs Dan
I'm going to send it to you in in a
WhatsApp okay yeah we got receips guys I
don't know uh we do serious reporting
here on the
podcast always all right so here it is
she's it's titled Mr Beast lied and eded
me out of the top three in creator games
3 whoa they lied to you
I participated in creator games 1 and
two and was excited to be a part of
YouTube's creator games 3 hideand-seek
at Sofi
Stadium go ahead why don't you bring her
in then okay and I'll I'll read it with
her
hi can you hear us can you see us yes hi
you guys than for having me I appreciate
it so nuts thank you for calling it's
it's been so long since we saw you I
don't know years I know it's been
forever and um right now um Mike's here
too this is Welcome to our hotel room
we're in Hawaii right now for the Hawaii
Food and Wine Festival I volunteer every
year I do uh cooking classes and then
all the money uh generated goes back to
community programs and we've been
working with them for like seven years
um awe they need it more than ever now
so welcome to the hotel room and the
Mike's here just helping me with text
stuff so I thought I'd just have them
say did I mention that uh turn mentioned
I probably must have by now that I used
to watch H to the Husky back in the
Starcraft days my I was like a [__]
it stop it no Starcraft head I was like
deep in the scene that he just started
gaming again a little bit on his uh the
new channel that he's doing we just we
just hang out and game in the evening
and dude he really enjoying I remember
the days when you used to watch that all
right he's he's being modest but in the
2 days he was a big deal he was like one
of the top announcers MLG that man was
out in Korea he was announcing the
biggest damn you know what I mean don't
be modest out there man the M yeah yeah
he's quite the gamer nerd he's
very so anyway he's he's uh he's moved
on and uh well it's not exactly the best
job in the world as I understand it
either is that right Mike it was rough
it I mean yeah I was doing tons of sh I
technically never went to Korea they
wanted me to go but I did like all the
mlgs and I think one year I did like 25
events and basically 30 you were
traveling all the time Ethan I don't
know if you know much about talking a
lot but it totally destroys your voice
if you don't anything
that yeah it is hard it is hard actually
sometimes yeah sometimes you just can't
do it anymore it's his fault he created
a monster with me he uh I started helped
me get started on YouTube and then
we really didn't we didn't anticipate it
kind of uh just snowballing I thought I
was just going to have my little cute
Baking Channel and just you know do me
my little part-time thing and have fun
but I it it just really blew up and so
we decided to switch gears together as a
couple
and managing me more and it just kind of
shifted a little but we we didn't
anticipate it but um we've been a good
team over the years I didn't know that
you guys created it together that right
from you guys were together before the
baking channel was
created a little bit we met actually at
BlizzCon uh watching Starcraft
2 randomly Sat by me and we got to know
each other and we I exchanged emails
with one of his friends cuz they were
shooting YouTube videos and I didn't
even know what YouTube
was they said well we need a girl we're
doing some music videos and stuff and I
was like I don't know talking about um
but they really were so sweet to me um
and so we kept in touch and we started
working together and then we just really
got along we work well together I loved
hanging out with him and and then yeah
we started dating later and I told her
yeah you're you're perfect for YouTube
you should do it you'll be huge um but
I'm not going to promote you for like a
year because I don't play that game and
so she made a bunch of like absolutely
terrible Vlogs like the worst Vlogs ever
seen on YouTube
okay the worst Vlogs I've ever seen I
fell asleep watching I mean she went to
a flight Museum and talked about the
flight attendant outfits for like 20
minutes I
mean history of wardrobe don't feel bad
rosna I used to send my early work to my
friends and they literally said Ethan
you have to stop sending me this
[__]
meop our early videos surprised I
survived after that I will never judge
anybody on their early video yeah he he
says he doesn't remember but I [__] oh I
don't know if it's helpful but Mike was
actually there with me at Sofi stadium
so whenever I go uh to sets or
Productions mike always comes with me
because he's my business partner and
manager but also um I briefly mentioned
this on the podcast I was just on but um
many years ago I had something really
bad happen to me on a professional set
along the lines of me too and um I've
never talked about it and I'm not I'm
not ready to but moving forward um we
just made a rule that I'm never alone on
sets um for my safety I'm sorry hear
that that happen Mike was there with me
at the creator games um
and the whole thing is Ju Just
was it's it's hard it was even hard for
me when I was like oh wait a minute I
have those clips cuz I totally forgot
about those
clips um that I had because I had to
Vlog on my phone and it was so hard for
me to just even watch those because I
was so happy like I was so happy to be
there and I was just like glowing and I
was so proud of myself and then to watch
it at now it
just cuz I just don't feel that way
anymore and it just kind of ruined it
for me so I guess the best way to oh by
the way I don't know if I mentioned but
pokem man is here too she's co-hosting
hello hi beautiful how are you good how
are you oh man what a weird week I know
and the dude the fact you guys met a
bliss con I was like
relatable I know oh my gosh I love that
so I think the best way to start is to
I'll I'll read your statement and then
if you want to supplement anything just
jump in while I'm reading it okay thank
you I really appreciate it yeah of
course um do you can read it if you want
I just I I don't know if you gosh I'm a
terrible reader but I I I'm dyslexic so
I mess up words but yeah Ethan is a
little bit too I am too long time I just
embrace it I'm not going to read it
people are like why did you wait so long
long to say something I'm like well I've
been writing this for an entire year
yeah um that was my joke but no I I am a
it takes me forever to read and right
but um um but but the the real reason
and we can we can talk about it is he
had us sign
ndas yeah and um that's a part of it and
the other part is I just
really value like my relationships with
people my friendships mean the world to
me
and I talked about a little bit before
but sometimes I put that above
myself and I'm learning that that's not
healthy and that I can't keep doing that
putting other people before me as a
detriment to myself it seems it seems
like you feel like this is a pattern of
stuff that's been happening to you and
that kind of what led to you making this
statement about that video right yeah I
think that I've allowed it to happen for
my entire life and I think it's because
of how I deal when deal with things when
bad things happen to me I hold it
in when bad things happen to me I just
hold on to it I shove it down I ignore
it and I think people know that I do
that
especially people that I get to know
when I work with so it opens the door to
really bad behavior because I won't say
anything MH I think a lot of women feel
also that that's just kind of the
expectation of them you know to hold it
in and just be polite and smile and not
be like annoying I completely agree you
have to stay silent and take
it and I just can't take anymore I'm
almost 40 I'm getting older and I said
it before but I feel like my trauma tank
is just
overflow it's just there's nowhere else
for it to go now it's just spilling out
of me and I don't think it's healthy to
hold on to it I I think it's really a
detriment to my mental health and um the
I I've labeled this my healing era I
really want to work on me right um so
are you are did you decide to break the
NDA by coming out or was there some kind
of
legal uh clarification you got on
it we'll
see we love that for you I I'll tell you
this R if anyone comes for you we will
stand in your way I uh I didn't
plan this it's just I like I was saying
it just my trauma tank is full I just
can't take anymore and it just came out
and I know what that's like well I'll
tell you this a lot of times ndas are
not enforcable at all depending because
you can't use an NDA to like hide um
malpractice you can do it so that people
don't share like spoilers right or and
secrets but like using an NDA to prevent
legitimate whistleblowing is is not
really a it's for yeah okay that makes
me feel a little better I am not a
lawyer too also I'll say that yeah but I
know a lot of good ones we've talked to
lawyers a lot where I feel like that is
something I think I kind of learned but
yeah I don't know yeah also it would be
so silly for him to go after you for
just genuinely sharing your experience
and your feelings right so I hope it's
not something you worry about you have a
lot of people on your side thanks I
really appreciate it and I um and when
the video came out I was at first my
reaction was I was disappointed that my
male friends didn't speak up for me
because I just were like wait you you
guys were there you know that that
didn't happen but I really took a lot of
time to think about it process it and I
realized that it's not their
responsibility to stand up for me it's
my responsibility to stand up for
myself and I've been getting a lot of
questions online from people like well
who can verify your story and I will
I'll say the people who can verify it
but I don't want people to pressure them
because it's not their fault they didn't
do
anything and they also had to sign ndas
you know and they probably don't want to
get in trouble and I don't know what
their relationships are also with Mr
Beast so the people that could verify
would be zhc he's so sweet to me I
really love him he found me with Mr
Beast uh they were driving driving in a
golf cart and I was in
transition and uh they found me and zc
gave me a big big hug um and but M you
know zhc is business partners with Mr
Beast
so I understand I'm not mad about it I
totally get it um and then Matt Pat Uh
who's a dear friend of mine I love him I
feel like he's my brother from another
mother um he didn't do anything wrong he
also is under you know an NDA and it's
not his fault that Mr Beast made these
editing decisions he has no say in it
right and then there's Logan Paul he
could also confirm what I'm saying he
was there in on it yeah he's part of the
conspiracy yeah him and I aren't close
uh we had positive interaction like
working together it was really fun we
actually did a shot of whiskey together
on our little lunch dinner Break um and
and I really enjoyed him I was actually
pleasantly surprised when I got to work
with him I didn't know what that would
be like and he was uh he had great
sportsmanship he didn't cheat he played
by the rules he was kind to everybody on
set
and so so here again I don't know his
relationship with Mr Beast so you know
and it's not their responsibility it's
mine to speak up for me
so let me catch everybody up I I'll go
back to the the statement and I'll just
read it here it's titled Mr Beast lien
eded me out of the top three in creator
games 3 I had participated in creator
games 1 and 2 and was excited to be part
of YouTube's creator games 3
hideand-seek at Sofi Stadium after
filming had wrapped I truly couldn't
believe how well I did at the
competition and was proud of what I had
achieved I had placed third when the
video was released I was shocked
disappointed and felt hurt that Mr Beast
had edited the video to make me look
like like I performed worse than I did
this was extra upsetting because I
genuinely believed him when he said that
his videos are authentic and real he
edited out he edited the video to make
it look like the final three people were
Larry Logan Paul and Zack King the final
three people are actually Zack Quack and
myself I think you hit on something
that's real important here is that this
he always overemphasizes that his videos
are authentic and real and so like if if
I was watching like a normal reality
show I would say like kind of expect of
course they always do that [__] they
edit it to make people look bad and
change the story and stuff but you don't
expect it from especially when it's like
a competition yeah you know with other
creators who have their own fans that
are watching and are taking as you said
so much time out of your day to even
participate how long was that shoot yeah
how long was the shoot over 24 hours so
I stayed up for over 24 hours straight I
think I was hour 30 that's a big
commitment and it was tough and the
reason I really got excited for it was
not only was it this fun competition
game with Mr Beast who at the time I
really admired I really loved like all
the charity work and videos that he did
I lik the you know planting the trees
and saving the ocean and I just thought
what he was doing was wonderful and and
I I just wanted to be a part of it and
support it because I thought it was
right on I mean I'm literally in Hawaii
raising money for the community so it's
just kind of um it touched my heart
that's that's why I wanted to be in that
environment and uh the winner got a
million dollars but not for yourself
it's not it was to give away to your
community and that amount of money
people like why do you care it's just a
game I care because $1 million to give
to my community is
lifechanging I could change people's
lives I could give a hundred people
$10,000 or I could give one person a
million dollars or I could give two
people half a million dollars like that
that is the ability to change people's
lives and my community I'm OG from you
I'm a 100 million years old
and the they have been with me through
everything for so many years and I love
giving back to them they deserve it um
so when I when I did this I was doing it
for real and he said it was authentic he
said it doesn't matter who wins because
it's you know all the money goes to
charity we're giving it all away we're
not keeping it for
ourselves um and and it just doesn't
seem like that's the case it's the
difference between like when you watch
wrestling where you know like it's
entertainment based and scripted versus
you're watching like an NFL football
game which you're hoping there's rules
and fairness and letting the athletes
complete and see what shakes out right
so in my mind I'm thinking it's a fair
game mhm but it's not so I'll continue
reading it here you continue for the
entire duration of filming we all wore
earpieces connected to walkie-talkies
they would announce in our ears when
someone had been found or when we had
moved hiding spots if we didn't move you
were immediately disqualified while I
was still hiding they announced that
they had found Logan Paul I couldn't
believe I UNL lasted him he's a fierce
competitor it was getting really late we
filmed for over 24 hours straight and
they eventually offered me money to come
out of hiding and quit which I declined
I had been counting the eliminations and
I was currently in fourth with Larry
quacky and Zack and myself still
remaining Jimmy asked us to move hiding
spots again to the side of the stadium
with the mannequins could I ask
something real quick yeah did they
specifically offer you money or they
offered everybody
money I know that in Mr Beast games when
they're going on for a while he will
offer people money to quit he'll also
offer people money to give up where
they're friends are
hiding like to disclose if you know any
information like I'll give you $10,000
if you tell me where so and so is hiding
um so there's a lot of those things that
happen um but I was at this point in my
mind I never thought I would even make
it that far so in my head I'm like wait
a minute I'm fourth like I could maybe
actually win this like so it started to
feel real for me because I've never I
mean I've been able to give back to my
community but I've never been able to
give them a million dollars
that's
huge so I just said it's not worth it I
don't want $10,000 for myself I'm here
for them so let's do this yeah I I know
I I I feel what you were getting at if
like he was specifically thinking like I
want to get her out specifically and
leave the other people in or was he
making the same offers to all for you
guys well I do know they mentioned that
we I don't know if it was in the walkie
talkie cuz we had a chest like a strap
on with a GoPro that was filming the
whole time so it was kind of like a cop
cam like it was always on and then we
had a handheld vlogging camera and half
of the time my vlogging camera worked
okay and then when it stopped working um
they said I could use my phone because
you can contact the walkie and you have
an earpiece so that people can't hear
you because they're walking so
loud um
so oh God I'm sorry where was I so I was
asking if they offered any of the other
contestants the like $10,000 to uh give
themselves up I wasn't sure but I do
know that GPS if they were having
problems finding people they can see
kind of what area you're in and they
came to my area many times but you guys
I'm such a good Hider they couldn't find
me um and the first time they I was in a
Cupboard on the ground the bottom floor
and literally the guys walked in there
and they opened all the cupboards and I
was like okay they're gonna they're G to
get me right here they're gonna get me
and I was in the smallest cupboard they
had like big ones medium ones and small
ones I contorted this little 4 foot 10
body into the smallest space and I was
in there for hours that they didn't even
open the door cuz they were like a
person can't even fit in there so they
went in there and they opened all the
cabinets and my heart was like oh
they're going to find they're going to
find me and then I could hear them
saying like she's not here I don't know
what you're talking about like she's not
here but I was they just they just
missed it
anden uh I'll I'll continue reading now
um yeah it was at this time that I found
in transition I was found in transition
moving to my next hiding spot when Jimmy
found me he brought me to the field to
be with the others that had also been
found I thought I placed fourth however
Larry had fallen asleep and hadn't moved
in a long time so he was disqualified
and that was an official qualification
right like over the radio everybody knew
yeah yes and then so this and and that
was before you got found so this meant
you got third place when I arrived to
the field and he hadn't moved many
times so I don't even know when he would
have got disqualified it could have been
like three rounds ago because he didn't
move for a while like he had a move move
move um but he he didn't move for a
while he fell asleep that is so Larry
yeah I love them yeah so when I arrived
on the field I I thought I was fourth
and that's uh the clip that I found um I
which I didn't even remember that I had
I and I thought I was fourth but then
they announced that AAR had fallen
asleep and he he's he's been asleep for
a long time so he was just disqualified
and so you got third then you say when I
arrived to the field I saw Matt Pat and
Logan there because they were Seekers
now too yeah Jimmy said he was going to
go look for Zach and asked if anyone
wanted to join him I offered to help but
he said he wanted to take his best
friend Logan Paul who is a
co-conspirator in this instead I may
have added some
words so I yeah the attitude was he at
that time I didn't
really yeah
I I'm sorry you're good you're good I'll
keep going so I hung back to looking for
Zach in a different direction with
mattad I placed third quack placed
second and Zach placed first this is
actually what happened despite Jimmy
editing the only female in the top three
out I was proud of what I had achieved I
followed the rules of the game gave it
my all had fun and never gave up they
can't take that away from me so he play
true true so you you he edited so it
looks like you got fifth yes you got
third and I agree that in a competition
like that for you to get to third
against other man is like such a fun
achievement that you were probably so
proud of that it really sucks that they
took that out of the result you know for
for people to see and just to be clear
there wasn't a gift the person who got a
gift was just first place
right I believe so yes um but I really
feel bad for quacky
because um I didn't know him very well
that's is the first time I met him and
he just seemed really nice and he was
really showing up for his community like
he was taking it serious he was trying
really hard he was in it some of the
creators the game just went on so long I
think longer than they intended they got
bored and they just quit yeah so but
quacky I just want people to know and to
hear that he never gave up he was out
there you know trying to get money for
his community he was he was doing it and
I I do think he was robbed I don't
understand what happened there either
other detail you shared with me is that
Zach the guy who won in your opinion
cheated because he was up in the rafters
he was in the roof which according to
the the um the rules that you guys had
all agreed to was that you wouldn't go
up climbing up into the roof and such
kind
of yeah so they had the written rules
but then they also before we started got
the group together and verbally went
over a few more things one of the things
that Mike's mentioned is there was this
fence they were very anal about this
fence like we could not climb the fence
touch the fence go over the fence there
was this big fence they made a big deal
like two feet tall wait how tall was it
it was it was like a twoot tall fence
that like I think went the length of the
field so it's like really a long fence
and they were using as an example of
like even this fence that's 2 feet tall
you should not be climbing over like
they were very the other thing that they
said is absolutely no climbing in the
air vents or the ceiling and they said
it's because they do all their wiring in
the ceiling right for obvious reason
right um not die hard it's just Mr Beast
right so I mean
if if it was held accountable especially
because this was a YouTube original
production Zach would have been
eliminated for cheating he broke the
rules and guarantee you if I claimed if
I climbed in the ceiling Mr Beast would
eliminate me mhm
so this all comes down to a I think
you're feeling like
um I don't know what's the word I want
to I want to word it correctly but there
seems to be I guess you're you're
feeling some misogyny that's that's
affecting continues to affect
your uh relationships with uh working
with people in general not just Jimmy
but in
general yes this is unfortunate I I
don't ever want
to believe that but it felt like a boy
club there that's the truth and I
understand that people don't want to
hear that especially if you're a Mr
Beast fan and you love him you know you
don't want to hear negative things about
somebody that you really admire or look
up to the truth sometimes is not
pleasant um and there it's also not
mutually exclusive people are saying he
didn't edit you out because you're a
girl he edited you out because you're
boring um and the two are not mutually
exclusive right he can edit me out
because I didn't fit the narrative he
wanted for who he wanted to be in top
three and he can edit me out because he
really didn't want a female there it can
be both and I just want to remind people
of that that it's not an or situation it
has to be one or the other it's just the
vibe I got all day
yeah even when like he would go and Vlog
with everybody um and even at the end of
the night when he said who wants to go
find Zack with me I offered and he was
like no I'm gonna take Logan right I
noticed you had mentioned that didn't
there was a lot of stuff that happened
like that which I would love to get my
hands on the raw footage because there
was lots of comments like that
throughout the day and it may just made
me feel a little sad um but I brushed it
off because it's a big production it's
stressful and I thought he might just be
in a bad mood but after I released this
statement I actually got three girl
female creators one's very big who said
that she had the same experience with
him and so it seems to me like this is
more of a pattern behavior and I totally
understand that people may not be
wanting to hear this or willing to hear
it right now and I think you know time
will do its thing I think the truth
always surfaces I know for a fact that
you know you you can't
keep I don't know the crap down it comes
out yeah seems like he probably has a
blind spot for I don't know what's his
uh demographic cutdown on gender but I I
can definitely see that he's having some
kind of blind spot that he's just
not it likely skews M yeah especially
being like a little gaming adjacent and
also like younger guys yeah the vibe
that I got there was that
oh gosh
um oh gosh I'm
like um take your time queen I'm like
how do I even say this I felt like he
had females there for Optics I felt like
he had females there also because it was
a YouTube production and you know they
wanted to have guys and girls be
represented but just cuz you're there
doesn't mean you're
welcome I wonder if you analyzed all the
winners of his videos and competitions
what would be the gender breakdown cuz I
I have a feeling it would be like
massively he does have he does have
women win and I think that's the other
part part of it is I think having women
present for Optics and then also he
makes exceptions for women who have very
large followings because he's a
businessman you know and at the end of
the day um if there's women with huge
followings he wants those numbers and
views those are his priorities so you
know like creator games 2 or one was the
demilio uh from Tik Tock gal one but
that's just a good business transaction
so that is the feeling that I genuinely
got um so I think some people watching
who are beast heads will say that uh is
that what they're called calling them
today Beast Boys
be
boys they would say listen it's just
it's not that serious it doesn't warrant
all this going out and talking about it
and making a big whole thing about it
and what would you say to to that
argument or that statement I don't
know I don't think that's
fair everybody's feelings are valid
especially in regards to gendered issues
because these are things that we deal
with over years and years and years and
years a time and when your trauma tank
is filled the [__] up when little things
going to be
Splash and either way if it's not a big
deal then he can just come out and say
hey I'm sorry that this happened um I
don't know how you know whatever getting
a million dollar is not a big deal right
I don't understand how giving a million
dollars to your community in any way
that you want to is not a big deal that
is a big deal and A6 hour shoot
nonstop that's what I wanted to add is
like he if he's presenting this as a
real competition and he's inviting these
people who have a life and have a job
and have aot time is things to juggle
and they are taking this very seriously
and playing by the rules it's just not
okay to then not follow the rules and
just do whatever you want they just
dedicated their time otherwise just hire
actors if that's why you want higher
actors you know by the way when I say
their time is valuable just because I
see people being like I mean that
they're busy thank you busy yes and and
a lot of people also accuse me of oh
you're just saying this for
clout
if I don't want any of Mr Beast clout
and I would just encourage people to
just kind of look me up over what I've
been doing the last 10 years I didn't
get in the baking game for
clout okay that is probably Community is
not a clout Community all right it's not
my it's not my cup of tea it's not who I
am I have said many interviews that My
Philosophy not only for life but for
business is a marathon not a Sprint I do
think life is very long I think the
choices you make matter um I take my
time with
things and I have never looked for a
shortcut or a quick come up this is
literally I cannot take people's crap
anymore I am so sick of it it is
affecting my mental health I'm over it
I'm done so you you've been carrying
this for a while it seems like you were
just kind of like that was so unfair it
sounds like according to what you're
saying quacky should have actually been
the winner and you should have got
second I think he was absolutely robbed
and he's a big Creator he has a
wonderful
community and he would have been first I
would have been second who would ever
thought little quacky and a little
baking nugget would make it that far I
think that that's a great story but it's
not the story he wanted to tell and then
the fact they included Logan Paul in the
top three makes no sense because he was
gone there's not even really he hung
around on set you know because you could
just hang and help seek if you wanted to
be a seeker and a lot of some people did
that for a while because you might get
more camera time or whatever they're
there so um but yeah that was that's why
think and in my opinion Logan is a
co-conspirator and also um he is also
responsible for everything bad that's
ever happened in the world I didn't know
you felt this way about I'm just kidding
I'm doing
sh I'm not a huge Logan Paul fan but
that that's irrelevant to this
conversation sry for another day yeah
and another thing that's just happened
is um another thing people were asking
me and I really appreciate you letting
me talk about this because it's so hard
to come out with something and then when
people have questions genuine questions
they want to know what's going on they
want more details I can't write back
thousands of people online over and over
again the same answer CL that's why I
want to do a good job of asking you
questions that detractors will say so
that you have the opportunity to address
them now yeah that and that's what I
want too because I I physically can't
write back everyone yeah of course and
answer all these questions it it's just
not possible and um another question
that I got was well why didn't you reach
out to him
privately why didn't you reach out
and what does it matter if you reach out
to him
privately is my question the video was
public yeah I found out when it went
public and he didn't have the decency to
contact me privately and tell me hey
just to let you know to make the video
more entertaining we cut you
out he he didn't give me a heads
up
and he
lied at first when it came out I almost
thought another thing people are saying
is Well what if it was just an editing
mistake yeah is it possible that it was
wasn't done in bad faith do you
think oh oh
oh okay so these are all the thoughts
that ran through my head when I watched
the video for the first time because I
liked him so much I wanted to give him
the benefit of the doubt I wanted to I
was shocked I was confused I was upset
and I was going maybe this was a mistake
like but then he recorded voiceover and
he said a blatant
lie so the voiceover in the video at the
very end part said says um we found
Logan
Paul I found Logan Paul literally one
minute before Zack
King oh so he's wait so he's trying to
even make it sound like he did second
that didn't even no that that never
happened uh Logan Paul was found while I
was hiding um hours dude that's so lame
hours before there's literally no reason
for me intentional that's not that's not
a oopsies that was intentional and um
another people are like well have you
talked to him have you reached out and
actually last night he did reach out to
me oh and oh my God Ethan I'm gonna send
you the messages oh
[__]
hold but can I answer from my point of
view when people say like why don't you
reach out blah blah blah um the fact
that she was in his video doesn't mean
they're best friends and she has like a
direct contact with him or has that kind
of relationship even to be like hey
buddy what happened it's like it's not
like that buddy you know but also like
she said the video is already out and
the video is already out the the the
narrative is already out there what does
it matter you already felt
like
disrespected Beyond I would never do
that to somebody else especially another
creator I've worked with and collabed
with so many creators over the years and
I'm upfront like if if it if it's a
genuine video it's a genuine video for
playing a game or playing a game like
I'm just upfront I what you see is what
you get and so I don't appreciate it
when the respect isn't
returned um and I think it's wrong yeah
especially when you ask send you these
I'm gonna send these messages so this is
oh okay Mike said he emailed him in so
um right now Mr Beast wanted to get on
the phone with me he wanted me to give
him his give me his number and call him
and talk it out I don't feel comfortable
communicating that way and here's
why he will not respond to me any of my
questions in writing oh he knows will
only he will only he keeps pushing it
three times you'll see call him call him
you are so right people do that to me
all the time too same here yeah same
here someone asks to call I say I don't
have a phone sorry the thing is write me
I've been burned so many times by people
learning that when I didn't know
anything you learned the hard way and
then I go hell no writing only we're
gonna need that answer in writing yeah
yep I and whatever he can say to me on
the phone he can say to me in writing
exactly and I know this unfortunately
because I've been in entertainment for a
really long time and unfortunately I was
in a situation different than this but
someone did this to me and I learn learn
the hard way and so I'm not doing that
again and I asked him flat out I'll show
you Mike is sending over the messages I
asked why he lied I asked he won't
answer he says he can't remember and so
the very last message I sent him I said
send me the raw footage and let's check
the
timeline and I got radio silence M yeah
yeah yep CA he's like dude that's
if yeah he knows if he puts God knows
what's in there you know if you sift
through the whole damn I mean God he's
never gonna share that no there's
comments he made to me on the elevator
with Matt Pat that are just rude I mean
there's a lot of stuff so we got the
emails here Dan's goingon to pull it up
or the the text or text right he keeps
pressuring me to get on the phone with
them and it's because he can say
whatever he wants on the phone to me lie
to me and then deny everything he said
you it's a it's a very it's a smart
business tactic he's a smart guy he's a
businessman cynical though yeah I mean
and I and I learned the hard way this
I've been I would say that you denying
the phone call is a smart Mo lick
because I feel like we've all had
something like that happen to us and so
now we know once it happens to you you
know can I give you a a Next Level tip
because this is what I did to bbtv yeah
I'd love it I if here's the best part
right you can use that against them I
had this problem with bbtv where they
had taken they had not paid me a ton of
money they owed me it's all resolved now
so I'm not I'm not trying to go after
them but because they were in Canada and
you got to check wherever he's calling
from there's tons of places that are one
party consent which means you can record
it and so when I got on the phone with
them they're being like overly Frank
they're being overly aggressive they're
being overly you know they're saying it
all like hey you know this is what it is
and so so by recording that legally then
you get you get their asses even harder
but I don't Jimmy's in where I Iowa or
something I mean I here let's see I
think North Carolina and I don't know
what their laws are I know in the state
of California you have to disclose when
you're recording on a phone call um but
I don't because he's in state I don't
know what the laws are and every state
is different I don't want to get screwed
again I already got screwed I don't want
to get screwed again
and so I'm just trying to protect myself
moving forward and um by the way it says
in North Carolina only one party has to
consent to the recording so get on that
call that means yeah that's
it I did not know the L when I last
night when he was messaging me I I don't
I'm not I I did not know so to be honest
it's pretty to record a phone call like
that is pretty sneaky you know it
doesn't it's not a good feeling not just
that but it allows you no time to really
think about what you want to say and it
allows someone to pressure you a little
bit easier cuz it's like a fastpac kind
of conversation they can say and do
whatever it's just easier to give
yourself time to say what you really
mean and they can do the same thing
right yeah and that's what I said to him
in the message I told him to kind of
like I can't remember exactly but I
you'll yeah you'll see it I said you
know take time for you to remember and
then let's talk
um and send and send me the raw footage
and then we can here I got the I got the
uh exchange here so here he messaged you
how long after your post did he message
you oh gosh I I'm not great at this
because uh we're there's a time
difference in
Hawaii like three hours five I don't
remember I don't know we were we were
traveling we driving
um was it a couple oh I don't know okay
that's fine so he says what's your phone
number I'd love to call and see if we
can figure out what happened you
responded your message is so
sweet I like it he said you said hey
Jimmy my intention of speaking up is not
to be malicious or create drama I was
really hurt by the editing decision you
made editing me out of the top three and
making me look like I I performed worse
than I did felt awful quackity was also
edited out of the top three oh wait
quack wait he talked about it yes he so
he I that's what I was also shocked by
cuz I have a clip on my I don't know if
I've ever seen a creator with more
engagement than quacky like he's huge
it's just in in like a more of like the
Spanish sector so maybe Mr Beast was
like oh that doesn't overlap I don't
know that's correct I'm surprised I
didn't hear that yeah and then he didn't
even get top three so um I didn't know
this a fan actually um sent me this can
you send that to Dan and we'll open it
yes s the link a year ago quack talked
about it and I didn't know that he had
talked about it and I'm really happy
someone sent me that CU it was at least
somebody kind of
collaborating
corroborating you're new to you're new
to this kind of Dr you're really new to
drama
legal just nice to have like I didn't
even know that existed so it was just
nice to like in my story I was saying
quacky was second and that's what he's
saying in the video and he was so
confused too like
what so what place did he say quack he
got second oh he got no he didn't say
that he got second but that's what he
act well he technically got he says it
in the video he goes
like who did Mr Beast say like oh who in
the video what place did you get who are
the top three in the video oh I don't
know what he placed him in the video I
think maybe it's in the message no the
first one maybe fourth wait he got
fourth no they have a little thing you
go to the end it shows you where they
put him it was a little confusing
because when I watched it last night
near the end is where the the Laray
disqualification happens and they just
kind of go straight from that into right
the the final winner or whatever so it's
kind of it's kind of ambiguous I guess
dude I'd be that's [__] up yeah um so
he did you put in the the the video here
what's this new album I'm trying to
weird so there was another video that
was longer but it's in Spanish so a fan
found this one it was in English which I
just really appreciate because somebody
did transcribe the Spanish one but it
it's still a little bit trickier to
follow so I really appreciated someone
finding something in English uh because
he's bilingual speaks both um so let me
let me read the text exchange and then
I'll pull up the video you said you
continue by saying it really hurt uh I
was really hurt by the editing decision
you made editing me out of the top three
making it look like I performed worse
than I did felt awful quacky was also
edited out of the top three and he also
talked about it I've stayed silent for
so long it's causing me mental stress
and anguish it's not mentally healthy
for me to have someone make me look
worse than I am to millions of people I
would never do that to a fellow Creator
said obviously I wasn't trying to make
you look bad just give me a time we can
chat I'm not mad or anything just want
to
help you responded why did you lie why
did you say in the video that you found
Logan Paul literally one minute before
Zach I outlasted Logan and was proud of
what I accomplished it actually built
some confidence in myself that there
that wasn't there
before yeah I see mhm he says I don't
know it's been a while let's call and
figure that's wild that's wild I don't
know been a while and I mean you were
being so vulnerable by saying that so I
I wish he affirmed your feelings a bit
more you uh respond erience I'll give
you some time to look into it and
remember and then we can discuss I'm
more than happy to review all the raw
footage to help show the timeline of
events feel free to send it over to my
team let me know and then he just goes
silent and hasn't written me back all
day yeah that was last
night just I mean
okay we didn't get the video link I know
I saw it somewhere where was it I saw it
in our document
somewhere my newest tweet um just pass
me yeah yeah Mike said he's having a
hard time at our hotel internet I'm so
sorry your internet's great by the way
yeah the call is
yeah we're trying our
best okay here I got it yeah yeah yeah
here it is basically every answer he
gave you was like okay cool but can we
get on a
call is it I mean just to give him the
benefit of the doubt or no not to give
but just to do The Devil's Advocate
thing it's I mean is it possible he's
super [__] busy and just didn't have
time to type [__]
out not
really things are always possible but I
think that Jimmy is very smart he is a
very smart
businessman it's also they're all
creators they're all busy that's true
everybody video quack got fourth but he
actually got second and then Rosanna
said the first should have and he should
have won he technically won by
disqualification I mean even from second
to Fourth still kind of sucks that's a
big difference yeah I agree but um all
right let me watch this clip but I will
say this I think Ela kind of had a good
point it's
that he should have been taking your uh
your opening up seriously and made time
to chat with you in the way you wanted
to yeah I think that if he actually
cared about me or my feelings that he
would right yeah right okay here's quack
talking so so I was I was in I ended up
being in third place I ended up being in
third place because they found me but
lay was in that video and lay was
asleep so I was technically second place
so I was I was the second place in that
video so so I was I was in I ended up
being in third place I ended up being in
third place he found me but lay was in
that video and lay was
asleep so I was technically second place
playing again yeah and then the other
aspect do you think Z do is there
anything you want to say about Zach
King's participation because it sounds
like
he I don't know if he it pro was it just
a mistake on his part he just kind of
was like yeah I won I mean is it his
spot do you think to say something like
do you think he even know he broke broke
the rules that he intentionally broke
the
rules I just yeah that's hard for yeah
it's
hard it's hard because I love Zach so
it's you feel slighted by him as well or
I just I adore him and
so it's hard it's hard for me to speak
up on things because I I adore him but I
what I do believe is in a fair game
right um if they're presenting a fair
game and there's rules and somebody
breaks the rules then I believe those
should be enforced um I grew
up another people are like well why do
you care you didn't even win right
that's a question I've been getting why
do you even care you didn't even win and
even if they changed it you'd come in
second or third who cares and I would
say I care because I do have good
sportsmanship
I'm I don't have a selfish mindset I'm
not like well if I didn't win who
cares uh I'm a team player I I feel bad
for quacky I think he was robbed um I
and he should have won and I also you
know I I grew up playing sports I I was
on Varsity soccer varsity gymnastics my
senior year in high school I was Captain
of our Varsity soccer team my team
elected me in that position I I wasn't
because I am a team player I car about
people and I do believe in a fair fight
and a fair game and I carry that into
this
game and it I was surprised as things
kind of got closer and closer I will say
I was surprised who had good
sportsmanship and who
didn't because I think as the money kept
getting realer and realer you know as
the people started narrowing down it was
really interesting to see people's
behavior MH and for as much as I didn't
like Logan for stuff he's done I was
really turned off by that he didn't
cheat and I was shocked but maybe it's
because he just makes so much money
anyways and I was
shocked did she you just didn't see it
but there's other people who they were
doing things I mean I was surprised by
Zach because um I just out of everyone
there I didn't think Zach would cheat
that's weird I mean that's weird yeah I
wonder if he didn't hear the but that's
up to Jimmy I mean it's all up to Jimmy
if Jimmy wants to have a fair game yeah
and enforce the rules he's gonna do it
and if Jimmy doesn't want to then he's
not going to and he didn't you know um
so uh here's one of the clips you sent
me that you had recorded here's you and
Matt Pat looking for Zach and saying
he's probably in the roof but you guys
oh I'm Delirious okay okay yeah yep and
so and then you're like well why would
we look in the roof that's not even a
legal hiding spot so here it is got
found there's two more people hiding
Matt believes Zach's in the ceilings I
do I but it's also the only place they
can be 4:30 in the morning so I I don't
know if this is coherent thought you're
in the ceiling he's in the ceilings
checked it the point is that it was so
absurd that you was there you guys were
joking not thinking
but he was right
mat Matt Pat is so smart he is like a
fierce Seeker I swear he was a detective
in another life I was telling him
there's no way that he's in the ceilings
he would never cheat it's probably like
a maintenance thing or something that's
why there's all the damage he's like nah
I think I think he's here Matt Pat is
smart he he was right wow here I'll
finish this all of the stadium he's
ventilation we're going to we're going
to jump up there but guess what he
turned into a gaseous substance right
right right right and now he permeates
everywhere Matt I found a key to a golf
cart want to join if it gets me off so
you guys weren't even allowed to look
for him by the rules that they set we
could be um I think Seekers no he saying
you couldn't climb oh no we could climb
up there that's what I'm saying you
weren't even allowed we weren't allowed
we were joking but no we U Matt did not
go up there I didn't go up there I
didn't want to you know make YouTube mad
at me because this was a I've been on a
lot of YouTube originals and I pride
myself on being easy to work with so
I've been on Markiplier's YouTube
original I've been on Jake roer's
YouTube original I've been on Joey
grappa's YouTube original I've been on
so many even TV shows HBO Food Network
NCIS G uh Nickelodeon Disney I've worked
on so many sets and um I I really pride
myself on uh trying to be good to work
with so I I don't go out of my way you
know if a production tells me hey this
part's off limits don't do it I'm not
going to be like yeah like that's just
so rude right and so I guess ultimately
what is there some kind of thing that
you would like to see Mr Beast do and
responses like what would what would in
your opinion be the perfect response for
Jimmy at this
point I really hope that he would take
accountability for the decisions that he
made and be honest because I don't think
if he isn't honest there's really no
place to go there's no room to move
forward or even mend things because if
someone isn't being honest with you he's
already broken that trust and if you
don't have honesty you don't have trust
and how am I supposed to forgive
somebody if they're not even being
honest right yeah
interesting I also hope that it helps in
the future because I may never get that
from him he may never be honest about
the
situation you know it's not like he's
going to go to Zach King and say hey
give me that million dollars back I'm
gonna go give it to quacky um I don't
think that's going to happen but I would
just hope that at least in the future he
might think twice before screwing people
over I'm hoping that by saying something
it's creating an environment where
people feel comfortable enough and safe
enough to stand up for themselves and
hold people's actions accountable I just
know that if I continue to stay silent I
feel like that behavior is just going to
continue and it's never going to change
it might even get worse
honestly and I don't want it to escalate
I don't want to be a part of that I
think you said your part and you know if
he wants if he wants to be honest about
it that would be that would be hard for
him to do you know what I mean like that
would be I'm just because he has so much
invested in like people believing that
his videos are 100% authentic you know
what I mean that I feel like that would
be a kind of devastating for him to have
to admit that
he that he that he was fudging the
outcome and because he supposedly
already gave the money what could you do
now I'm sure he's got another million
smash away somewhere you know I'm not
going to lie I was just hoping he would
take it a little bit more in stride like
for those saying oh it's not a big deal
or for starters it's it's kind of the
principle of the thing but two if it
wasn't that big of a deal then it
shouldn't be that hard to say like I'm
sorry that must have sucked MH and I
mean it really can just be that simple
like I think it's very understanding to
be like oh it's suck that you showed
that you were placed worse than you
actually were and there was no ill
intent and move on I I I was hoping
that's what we would see in those
messages yeah me too I I'm just getting
attacked right now by his fan base there
girl I know what that's like yeah I'm
only yeah they're like you're only
speaking up because your YouTube channel
is slow I was like my channel has always
been slow I am literally slow and steady
and I am so happy with all the success
that I've achieved in my life like I
came from nothing I am more than happy
with where I am in life and Mike and I
have created many businesses that are
not online that I don't even think I've
told people about um but you know we
also develop TV shows and I'm doing TV
shows in merch and we have so many
different revenue streams it's not about
money it's not about Cloud it's not
about any of that it's about what's
doing what's right and it I just hope
people can hear that even if they're not
ready to
um it's just really disappointing and
it's really sad and the video I think
I'm going to post it on Twitter it's
when when I'm Vlogging and I get caught
and I'm I'm so excited you can see here
I have it do you want me to open that
one yeah it's like and it's hard for me
to watch but be but it you can really
like you can feel it here let me let me
find the one it's the one where this is
when we didn't know lar Laray had been
asleep so I thought I was fourth but I
was third here here it is so when I came
down the first floor I was hiding
underneath like oops like a metal
staircase and I could hear people going
up and down it and then Jimmy chose to
move again so I jumped into an x-ray
machine and I was hiding in there and
then he said we had to move to where the
mannequins were on this side of the
stadium and I think I was already on
that side but I didn't know that and so
I got out of the X-ray machine right
when Jimmy is driving by on a golf cart
just oh my gosh just bad luck but I made
it to uh top four fourth place uh so I'm
really proud of myself because that's
just a miracle never thought I would
make it this far and this has been an
amazing day like what is my life this is
incredible thank you
Jimmy right so you took that away from
you yeah the joy you had in that
moment yeah yeah well hopefully you know
hopefully he sees this and
um ends up talking to you in a way that
that that you would like you know what I
mean that that's my hope is that maybe
there'll be
some satisfying conclusion to this but
we'll see you know like I said I think
it's going to be tough tough for him to
swallow his pride and admit that he
fudges the numbers yeah I think it's a
hard thing to do I also think being
young is hard I've talked about that
there's a lot of mistakes you make
there's a lot of growth to be grown true
yeah and I I don't know if he's at that
level I don't know if he's mature enough
to get there yet and again I'm not in a
hurry um I think the beautiful thing
about time is really anything can happen
and I'm a very forgiving person I'm
really open I just you know things first
need to happen and we just won't know if
they will
um just to end it in a nice note Olivia
here is saying that uh you taught her
how to do her science fair project in
Middle School yes you did are you trying
to make her feel old in sixth grade I
did the dipin dots experiment because of
you cuz I thought it was so
cool so oh my God I just L it I know
thank you so much I'm such a big
fan here let me pull up that video so
fun doing that I love playing with the
uh the years ago yes it was so fun my
parents did it with me this is from 10
years ago wow oh
no is this the one
yeah oh my godid nitrogen Nerdy Nummies
hey guys welcome to another episode you
the boys would love that I'm going to
skip to the's
see nerdy sying I'm just going to mute
it yeah ohes like and so how was your
experiment it was successful Olia my
teacher loved it yes I can I I'll on
Monday I can show you guys I still have
the board it's
beautiful that's awesome yeah that's so
funny There You Go respect Dipping Dots
easy to make a well you made my year my
science
year that's awesome those look beautiful
we should do DPP we
should absolutely so good well I will
say this um thank you so much for
calling and sharing your story with us
yeah thank you thanks for having me you
guys I really appreciate it
I it it just feels good to be able to
like try to answer all the questions at
once so I I can just is there anything
else that you want to address maybe
before we hang
up I can't think of any m is there
anything I
forgot no no I think that I yeah I I
think it's good now I can finally just
I'm going to go uh go bake some cookies
in
Hawaii cuties so are you you must be one
of those people that bakes a lot but
doesn't eat the baker stuff you just
make other people eat it that's what a
lot of people think and they're very
wrong I love food and Mike was making
fun of me even on uh the show our new
Food Network show we got a second season
it's airing right now and um I'm hosting
with Dev Goldman and I I literally
forgot we're on camera like I'm eating
this cookie like just
like
it's so so I eat all the baked goods on
there is she says sheat but she's not a
feeder I I get bigger as the season goes
on so our wardrobe progressively gets a
little bigger and bigger and then you
know I my mom is Italian and eats a lot
of Mediterranean diet so then during the
week I try to eat really healthy I try
to counterbalance it but I have a major
Sweet Tooth I love food and in college
it got out of control you guys in
college I was obese I'll I'll post a
picture online but I that's when I had
no balance I'm I'm I'm better with
balance and portions now but I really um
I love food I love it me too girl me too
sory in my life Rosanna poncino thank
you so much a pleasure joy to hear from
you and uh I thank you very much for and
H the Husky husy nice talking to you as
well later nerd
nerds the mic bye have fun in Hawai
thank
you
byebye and that there you go the laptop
closing I love that quite figured that
out like I'm always the last one to hang
up on a zoom call same cuz it takes like
three clicks like bye uh bye uh bye
people are so well trained though like
as soon as we finish a call they're like
done and I'm the last one like draging
my mouth um speaking of which there's
actually okay so Jimmy's on standby
Jimmy Lee I know his time is oh my God I
thought you were saying Jimmy Mr Beast
you're like you about to interview them
both Jimmy Beast is here
all and now
jimy you see I have I need to run to the
bathroom which I I have to do now like
so many times I have to do two and I'm
not
pregnant you
know so um are you a Jimmy Lee fan do
you have thoughts do you know who that
is the Jersey Outlaw the what Jimmy Lee
the Jersey Outlaw I don't believe I'm
familiar so he is
a he's a New Jersey comedian the
show wait can you pull up a photo
mhm speak with yeah but before he's on
you
know oh my God here he is I'm trying
with one hand here
there you go give me a leave oh world
famous
wait why does he look so
familiar wait a
minute je how do I blow that
up hold on so M this hold on
[Laughter]
guys son of a [__] am I there
glasses I got new glasses I got them for
Hill she asked me to get there Teddy
fresh am I on Can You Hear Me is my mic
working hold on one sec
hello just a sec hold on one sec
hello okay you're on Can You Hear
Me Gabe can you hear him can can you
hear me I love G my audio on or
no Gabe is the audio
working can you hear Jimmy Gabe says yes
so go ahead Gabe can you hear
me oh he can hear you hello
now do I need to fix the
audio you're good you're good do you
want these instead
AA these are what the Jews wear in
Florida they can't see they're thick
glasses GC colist
glasses you like those better or do you
like the chanels these are the chanels
that Zach bought
me which ones you like oh hi white claw
Gabe look at
him I like the Chanel's
personally who said that uh just a a
friend of the show my name is poke
friend of the show okay I'm I'm G to do
what you tell me to do happy to help
beautiful gorgeous stunning beautiful
beautiful well thanks for having me on
guys sorry everybody's um in the
bathroom right now it's just me and you
actually okay well how are you what is
your name my name's Pokey hi Pokey I'm
Pokey too I'm Jimmy nice to meet you
Jimmy happy to meet you tell me a bit
about yourself what's that hun tell me a
bit about
yourself um I do Street comedy and I'm a
dentist and I'm trying to um you know
get in the entertainment business more
and uh get a little more famous doing a
true multiphen it can I give a you're
you're a Moroccan right yes so do you
have any jokes about oh no I'm Jewish
how you get me to be Moroccan hold it
hold no me me I'm oh you you okay I
apologize oh wait a minute let me see
you pokeemon man I just saw her hi
sweetie nice to meet you hi nice to meet
you too do you have any Moroccan jokes
or no me no no not a single one we're
not enough to be poked fun out oh you
want to hear something Pokey man really
funny sure my buddy he's a guy he lost
100 pounds during the second half of
coid uhhuh but during the first half he
gained 95 PS so in essence he only lost
five pounds damn quick math I wasn't I
wasn't had a hard time following that
[Applause]
one wait how is that picture making
noise that's crazy gab that was so
mean Gabe I got another joke would love
to hear it you know how to get a fat
girl in bed do I know how to what you
know how to get a fat girl in
bed it's a piece of
cake oh that's kind of okay I kind of
like that one honestly that could get me
in bed too so
oh sounds good to
me gab nice to see you buddy we love you
what's in that red Solo cup just
curious uh a lot of viagran Alice to be
honest it's liquid though I make it
liquid see see liquid Viagra and SE
you're desperate out there guess what I
did pokem man last
night guess what I did poke man last
night you got two boners going or what
boner I had some Agra and Ethan gave me
some prune juice and now I don't know if
I'm coming or going oh my good
God is prune juice to poo well hold on I
don't I don't understand that joke
because if you're coming we know what
that means if he's going to the bathroom
yeah I get it good one thank you pokey
man for that I you're so welcome I love
to explain jokes it really just sucks
the humor right out of
them doing real bad so far we'll try to
get one more good one in
take your time we
love oh I have another
one hold on one
sec joke
loading you
ready go ahead okay what so my wife my
wife Pokey man had her eye surgery and
and she just dumped
me try that again my wife had her eye
surgery she just dumped
me who's this
guy who's that
guy this guy poy man who's that guy with
the ear
looks like he has Chanel earrings who's
that guy he's one he's a new employee
he's actually he's here to live react is
that a son is that a
son he's here to live Jimmy he's here to
live react to your jok so try to make
him laugh go
ahead I I think he needs to get his
camel I mean who is this guy who what
who is
he is that the K Buffy muy
I think I think Pokey man is a khif
Muffy muy from the Sinai
desert what do you mean by that exactly
take a look at him he is the khif muy
muy he's the guy on the camel from the
Sinai desert I think that reference is
dating you is that dating me okay all
right but go ahead let's his let's his
name is gidas let's see if you can make
him laugh he's a tough I believe in you
he's a tough nut Gus
gas did you hear about the two judges
they tried each
other gidus is that a unibrow what's
going
on g a snap out of it get off to se
Alis go to London go on a vacation city
as everybody comes do something snap out
of it get a piece of pizza call dock
call Zach get get some matah do
something it's not going to work work
Ethan he's tough he's a tough one the
unibrow is not he's not budging thei
ain't moving the Joe brck was good
though I like
that look JY actually brought you on
here for a reason yes okay not just to
uh I'm I'm afraid to ask but what are
you guys eating they look great are they
wraps just wraps Jimmy where are they
from it's really good actually
California Cafe I think the next time
that I come out I'm going to bring some
of those wraps they look good some
hearts and Minds doing that they're good
Bo they look they look yummy yummy
listen we love pinks because they
support you but it's time to move
on wait a minute no more pinks Mr Pink
would kill me I'm just saying not
everyone's always in the mood for a boy
dog okay well the RS do look good though
are they Subways they look like subway
RS all right let's let's uh as much as
lunch is interesting to talk
about um I I have a question for you I
saw a comment that you left on Instagram
okay and I wanted to ask you a few
questions about it okay okay so if we
look at you you're a fan of Sophia
Vergara no she she actually reached out
to me how do you know about
that what do you mean she's got the
she's got the for me I don't know if you
know she's into you yeah she's got for
me I don't know if AB mentioned
it it's a gastrointestinal
[Music]
thing it's the hots it's the hots it's
the hots poy man knows she knows for
sure for sure here's wait just to
clarify she reached out to you or you
reached out to her oh she's got as I
said for me yeah I didn't reach out to
her I responded to her a so Jimmy here's
the photo she posted herself looking
beautiful mhm uh someone might call a
mil trap I don't
know I'm not sure how to refer to
it if you scroll down I you see that uh
the Jersey Outlaw left the comment you
said quot you're my favorite Sophia
please reach out well you don't miss
anything we need to do a collaboration
together I'm a famous comedian on the
streets let leave what the hell wait
whoa whoa whoa what's that laughing in
the background I B it what was that
Laughing pokeemon Man about the famous
comedian thing that was a that was ay
boy that was King
Jew true he is King jew though that his
new nickname is Rock and Roll Jesus I
have another name for him let's not
let's not off you skate here Jimmy do
you remember leaving this
comment yeah I left it in response when
she vied me yeah
absolutely you said please reach out
that doesn't suggest that talked before
I did not to be official but she had
reached first because it's obvious why
you know people reach out and how did
she reach out to you via what
channel Instagram Instagram she so she
met what is she saying when she messaged
you on Instagram huge fan and and let do
with collab So I responded to her to
that wow and you said please reach out
why would you say please reach out just
to make it official it's making it
official
what does that mean make it official you
have to make it official because the uh
the post is public the DM's private so I
spoke to all my people and they said you
didn't put it up there official because
as I told you she's got the for me which
I I repeated that earlier and and did
she respond to your she must have
responded to your comment here then
right no in the DM she did already yeah
okay right can we see the
DM well that's all private that's that's
is holding all that stuff right now so
okay what kind of collaboration are you
guys looking to do together we're that
we're we're talking the teams are
talking right
now that's really
exciting you guys is she gonna be like
one of the girls that accompanies you
when you're doing Street comedy or no we
may we may do the AGT thing oh you're
gonna be on AGT possibly nothing's
nothing's in stone yet wow well that
makes sense you are also friends with
Howard Mandel well that's because of you
you you what you did I'll never forget
you buy me up with him and we went on
and that went well and I love you for
that E I love you too Jim no I love you
I owe you my owe you my life for getting
me on how they love me and I was I was
hoping
you and you did I it's the truth I told
Zach that too you would be dead without
me uh I wouldn't be dead I'd be dead
dead dead and did you make a decision
regarding Bobby Le's podcast you're
coming out for that right uh not sure on
that one yet I'm waiting for the live
show
invite really about the live show we
want to get play in the piano we want to
play the piano laughter of love right on
the all right Jimmy I I'll break it to
you that's not happening I know Zach
told me okay I'm sorry know it's not
it's not that I don't love including you
it's just that you have too much on the
live show he told me we had a whole big
thing of you last year it was like one
of the main segments so I got you it's
cool we'll put you on the burner for a
minute or the ice pad no listen
everything you do for me I appreciate
and love and if I'm on the sideline for
a little while I'm not going anywhere
you're welcome to come you know what I
mean you can come be backstage with us
you can hang
out maybe you can be a warmer maybe you
can do an opening set before the show
starts that'd be fun right I don't know
I'm I'm thinking of it's a little harder
in November to get out there because I
business Jim did you say this de I may
come out Jimmy did you say this you said
the analytics on Bobby's show was not
good enough to Warrant you going oh my
God oh my God no no no I didn't say that
that guy said it right there Jimmy what
what about his analytics is not good
enough for you the timing's bad because
of my job I told Zach yesterday it's a
very hard time in November a doctor is
going out on a medical for a couple days
and it's that same week it's difficult I
may try to come in December I told I
text Zach yesterday I'm being upfront
with you um what did he tell you exactly
Zach um he told me he's got some issue
going on with his uh uh practice and um
some doctor I think had a health problem
correct and I kept reiterating and Dan
and I have been figuring out dates with
Jimmy contacting Bobby's producer and
Jimmy has given me dates and originally
Jim Jimmy wanted to do December but they
can't do December so he gave me some
true in November okay and we we I sent
Jimmy relayed him that information
yesterday and he's like ah the inals
aren't that good I I don't know if I
want to do it no I said there's not
enough things going on that date and I
said I have a doctor out I said that
just the whole the whole thing the
timing what if we can find a better
timing for you is that or would it would
it be worth it coming out for this show
if we can find a better timing where you
know it doesn't interfere with work as
much well because what happened with Dr
Tom you know it would have to go back
probably another week or so but um I
don't think originally I well I'd
originally planned to do December but
now that I'm not going to be on your
thing I don't know really what to do so
I was planning honestly not even come
until maybe next year now I don't know
worth it well you got to understand I I
leave my business I lose money I'm not
producing and I spend money and I'm
older and I have to plan things out more
because I'm older so you know I have to
be a little logical are you dipping into
the retirement
fund no no I'm I'm not dipping into the
retirement fund but business isn't what
it was Ethan and um you know I have to
be a little more frugal know what I mean
that's a good way to say it which is
what I'm doing I will rig it so you win
oh here uh Mason actually sent us the
DMS damn she actually did message you
she said Jimmy I love your comedy and I
love you with all my heart you said work
with me she said come on America's Got
Talent I will rig it so you can win
that's crazy and then she said leave me
a comment like we just met so we can
make it official my this is cute so at
least at least you're seeing the DMS
which is good so I'm glad to see you
Soul nothing deceitful there Jimmy
you've been telling the truth about
every damn thing see you don't miss
listen listen pokem man they don't miss
anything it's it's true they're
detectives out here to be honest they
are smart Jimmy how many followers are
you up to on Instagram well is Sam is
Sam
there you're at 1.2 million conat wa is
Sam there is Sam there no um she went
outside for a second yeah but because I
think a new cake would be in order when
I do come out cuz we hit 1.2 million
today W think need a new cake when I
come out wow he really wants that cake I
wonder why yeah Jimmy um I wonder why we
analyze his followers and he do a huge
following in Brazil like
80% That's So Random why he also gets
more follow we did a we did a whole
shoot there in the summer for a month
poke man they love us in brail he also
gets more followers on a daily basis
than Kylie
Jenner wow how much do they
cost now now be nice this is the Jersey
Outlaw this is the Jersey Outlaw be nice
just a little silly come on Pokey man
right now I'm I'm you're in my corner
come on don't don't worry you can call
me pokey okay we're friends like that
pokey pokey don't
push don't push please I won't I won't
push yeah just being a little silly now
Jimmy before I silly mood I do want to
give you some
feedback obviously it's a really tense
time right now I personally didn't find
it very appropriate that you dressed up
like
Hamas what how you find saying work with
did you tell him I told Hiller I told
Hiller not to tell you Hiller you
promised me you weren't going to tell
him you should really talk to Mason cuz
that was [__] up that was a badst way
too far why would you put a headband on
yourself Z wait a minute put the camera
Zach you're all red what are you doing
aiz you [__] what are you drinking
you son of a [__] what are you
drinking coffee geez you're you're red
you're [__] that thil thank you for
making fun of my red face again as if I
didn't know bot Christ junk
cook yeah that one you already know what
I'm talking about was it who is that
who's that you don't know who that is no
who is that Olive who is that very very
popular Korean Idol and Jun cook I just
throw him up Mason makes him and I throw
him up that's all I do that's a smart
move that's a smart business move I'll
tell you that my that's a smart business
move yep hold on Jimmy cuz you said
Mason just puts it up and you don't even
know who's in these so when I tell you
something and you assume I'm joking I
really need to cut in if you look at
this one for example oh no that's you
Jimmy he looks great in that photo do
you know who this girl is that's Olivia
Rodriguez good jri
that is a okay just so you know look at
it her music makes me want to blow
myself up it says she she is a member of
Hamas I'll have you know that right now
you literally are supporting Hamas
terrorism by po [__] crazy bro she's
Spanish I'm just kidding she's she's
innocent I'll make that clear she's a
very good friend too by the way I'm
pretty sure she's Filipino I'm pretty
sure also is she Filipino yeah what's
the is she
yeah we should work with them more
honestly be nice be nice Filipino or
Spanish I think it's I think Filipino
okay and definitely not Hamas that was a
joke she's a Filipino American yes okay
all right so um with that Jimmy I
congratulate you on connecting with
Sophia gar Sophia I think that was nice
you you acknowledge it and I love you
for that and uh I'm going to let you
guys know how that works out hopefully
we can't wait to see the collab
yeah I I I'll I'll let you guys know
I'll let Zach know if you need any
funding for marketing let us know would
you help me pokey
potentially well if you're interested
reach out to me I would love to speak to
you further about
that
seriously get this guy off the screen he
hasn't smiled once he looks like he's at
a viewing I mean God Almighty I'd rather
spend the day and watch a fly go up a
Drake and hang out with this guy look at
this guy died two weeks ago and nobody
told him I never met a
mannequin Z get rid of this guy he's a
pain in the ass get them
off
boom connect the dots pal connect the
Brows
boo all right Dan that's a
wrap pokei that's a
wrap all right all right Jimmy Lee
[Applause]
everybody shout out to
our that was like art the F to the
background was good I like that that was
very good laughing Jimmy in the end
uh it was the unibrow joke I think yeah
holy [__] that was so funny yeah you
guys download this song Nightmare on
iTunes by e f it's only 99
you can hear all my fans singing
it everybody knows the words of you're
going to perform it at the live show
more so cuz of you than cuz of dream to
be honest who dream don't know oh but my
bad nightmare nightmare nightmare it's a
nightmare yeah yeah thank you we don't
we don't know who that is also I watched
your guys' episode with Bob on tiger
belly but like you guys had one right
yeah yeah but like a hot minute ago yeah
I watched that one it was years ago good
I'm like scared to even it got like did
good number wise for them I mean I was a
fan of you guys you think of the camera
angle but I haven't watched in a while
oh so okay wait there's the first one
that we did and had a good time the
second one is when he hit me with the
camera angle I don't know if you know
about yeah that's the one that he me up
y That's funny though I forgot about
that that was Peak I looked like Humpty
Dumpty
but it's PE cuz you Meed it you know I
was egg is that where it started whole
angle thing yeah well so well no started
on hoe there was an angle issue on hoe
as well yeah where I
looked TIG belly was the first one and
then how we followed uh followed in life
well there you go um we've got so much
still to get to but what a what a
terrific uh fantastic start to our show
huh yeah with a food break with a food
break as Jimmy and fidus took the lead
on the convo and girl what is that oh
Howe Mandel gave that to me here you wow
oh right this was this oh but this was
the Howie one not the tiger belly one
but this one was equally bad this is so
I
remember they wanted they wanted to
memorialize the uh the
angle thank
you that just showed up in our house one
one day on the couch and I was terrified
I like that the leg is like it's really
hanging on for too
long it really captured my
voluptuousness yeah um actually you know
what I'm going to go PE real fast and
then I want to come back and talk to you
about some of the recent news that
you've been involved
in me
mhm I'm an open book what can I say and
here is my the cover of my new
album
it's called nightmare it's my it's my EP
that's sick so everybody check me out my
my face name is
[Music]
um my my face name is um um
sleep you have a really unique look my
angelism is sleep I've never seen that
before I like the whole mask thing
literally I've never had my face you
know I like the Myster the Mystique I
like it too you know what I just
realized ELO looks like the Doomer girl
meme
today I'm talking about I don't know
where this wait you guys need to
photoshop that you don't know Doomer
girl she's cute very
cute yeah you know oh my God so cute I
got to say this this WAP is what is that
is it hit it got soggy I waited too long
oh no it was so good though oh you like
her the Melrose one yeah the extremely
wet I got a bail on it though I'll be
right
back
um I think you're all good what is the
Doom girl from is it just like a little
thing just react meme yeah it's from I
don't I don't know where it originally
came from usually those all those uh
images have like some Source image that
it was based off of let me see if I can
figure it out I think the Doom girl is
based off of another girl
meme let see if I can find there's like
the Chad and then the
girlfriend and then maybe there was like
a doom version of there's like a Doomer
guy too it's the one that's like smoking
that you always see this guy yeah okay
yes it's just there's a whole cast of
characters here oh Tim P yeah that's him
pool character
exactly a few weeks later he shaved that
was cute
actually like very
holesome well I do feel like Doom girl
what everything that's
happening understandable I think we all
do a little bit Doom girl be a cute
Halloween costume true true yeah I don't
know if many people would recognize it
though that's true maybe if you made
yourself look really 2D o yeah you could
you could do like grayscale type paint
that' be sick that would be really cool
not do you guys have your Halloween
costume yes we do what are
they well or maybe no spoilers we have
some surprises well here's the thing we
all have two basically because we like
to make life Harden ourselves cuz we
have ones for the show next month where
and then the actual memes from the show
and everything but then we have a
Halloween party that we're all going to
and I think everybody has a different
costume for that one too I was going to
go with the same one I think I'm going
with the same you're going to go with
the same one okay so say I was going to
say we could say our party ones cuz
those aren't going to be seen on the
show you can anybody that's I have I
have four costumes what oh my God huh
why well I don't want to wear the same
one to like any
events that's a full-time job bro
costume for each thing that I'm doing
can you share any of them
yeah uh I can share one I will be being
the Wendy's mascot amazing that's so
cute I love you are Wendy when I was
initially G to come for the Halloween
show I was going to do genderbend Vape
Nation so that but like in a girly way
with like a skirt and the bandana and
all this stuff then I was like I don't
know if the audience would like it that
much so I was dming young F and I was
like what do you think of this I I said
you should go for it but there's a lot
of people who might not know people that
don't know about Vape ntion you don't
think so maybe I don't know there are
probably yeah there probably are these
days like a whole different life
yeah whole different internet so I would
like to ask you some things go ahead
first of
all train wreck who is a giant piece of
[__] that is not what I thought you
would ask me about at all I have other
things okay what did you think I would
ask you about I thought it might be the
Sniper Wolf tweet that's
coming this feels like um what's that
thing that people do in church like
confessional you know 20 bloody
maryy yeah confess your sin well the
other day I tweeted this so uh train
wreck who uh we all know as the gambling
uh Lord degenerate [__] loser psycho
like I actually just really despise him
um he said about uh pokei that she was
the most corrupt person on Twitch what
yes is that a tweet I don't have the
Tweet what or so okay the do you guys
know the context of him saying that no
please educate me no the context is
actually Insanity so remember when um me
Hassan a few people were advocating for
gambling to be banned on Twitch yes so
during that time obviously train was not
a fan of mine at all but you know it
wasn't even against him I just that's
what I wanted for the platform
personally mhm there was a call that
train and xqc leaked to Destiny so train
xqc mkf asmin gold I don't know who else
they all had a private call and of
course someone recorded it and then they
gave that recording to another streamer
and then that streamer Live recorded to
this private conversation between four
of like the largest male creators on
Twitch and they were just saying some of
the wildest really it was so weird yeah
I no idea we talked about it a little
and that so it was in this like private
conversation private call that was
intentionally leaked mhm and they're
obvious I mean some of them are saying
not cute things about me and train is
like yeah she's the most corrupt person
on Twitch and I'm sat at home watching
like 30,000 people live react to this
call yeah okay it was very very odd
circumstances first of all for train
wreck to accuse anyone of being corrupt
yeah how is that going to come out of me
playing valerant 98% of the time on on
stream she so corrupt I don't know this
dude is such a [__] piece of [__]
talk about corruption the dude left
twitch and started a new competitor with
basically embezzled [__] uh sh money
uh embezzled
uh uh uh uh funds what do you call
laundered money oh just straight up
cryptocurrency getting K getting tons of
people addicted do the most the
deadliest Vice there is for I say it's
embezzling and I say it's money
laundering that's my opinion I don't
have I'm not privy to any I like when
you guys did your little um the little
Sherlock Holmes thing looking up the
address figuring out where what where is
this LCC located it's LLC sorry small
Hut
and and so this dude accusing anyone of
corruption is it was just so Random to
me so here's your response although I
want to hear that video does anyone have
it it's hours long is there not a
highlights real I mean there's like a
live stream fail like rubric for it I
just put it in the chat if you wanted to
see it's so long yeah it was insanely
long yeah so they're just being oh I
didn't know that so asmin gold who was
in it asmin gold yeah pretty it was like
an otk meeting now and then no no no no
this was when Miz and train Rex had that
big blowout on Twitter and so this was
supposed to be like a almost like a
Reconciliation kind of call I think but
xqc was there asmin was there and I
don't know who else was Miz kff saying
main things Miz was actually this was a
reason that like Miz and I's
relationship had a falling out for a
while he wasn't necessarily saying bad
things about me but he wasn't also you
know he he was yeah and he was more so
saying like oh train like I don't feel
that way about you it's like Hassan and
Pokey that are like after you in a way
um but I know Miz had like his own
things to deal with and we've already
resolved it so you
know there's something I've noticed
about twitch that I don't I have no
uh I don't understand it because it's
just so not my world but there seems to
be like high level collusion where all
the top
streamers they all like there's not a
lot of them there's like maybe 10 15 I
don't know and they all [__] talk and
they all know each other and like if
there's tension or beef they like they
talk about it and move
on which is probably good on the whole
but on the other hand it leads to wait
you think they talk about it and move on
I don't know they talk about [__] like
this call is is evidence like oh I don't
think this call would ever happen like
you know PA and it's because honestly
there David do it's cuz everybody like
twitch is such a bubble if something's
going on in it there's no way around it
you need to go through it essentially M
so I I think that's why it's a little
more confrontational than perhaps
YouTube where people can kind of reside
in their own Islands which I personally
actually like about YouTube I feel like
we're in our own Island yeah most and
you can just say and do whatever and
it's like you and your and your
community but twitch is like one huge
community and because there's um
directories someone else's viewers can
come to you so easily you know it's like
in a way there's something about it that
sounds kind of nice maybe but I feel
like in reality it's a very toxic it has
its pros and cons for sure so I mean you
know yeah sometimes I'm like oh I wish I
was more of like a YouTube streamer I
don't know doesn't open anything frozen
cons for sure yeah I click
these um
oh you send me a new
one the call is there the call that call
was look at it's 5 hours oh yeah look at
all ins asmin gold I it's interesting
that he showed his ass to be a [__]
piece of
[__] that's [__] up I used to look up
to him you know who cares about xqc
crazy he's got a nice watch apparently
and brain wreck we know is basically a
criminal I mean in my opinion dude has
literally no ethical
uh light in his life mkf I don't really
know that much about he should have
spoke up for you I don't know who the
[__] this I wish but I know who's the
last person Mitch Jones I don't know
this person yeah or this person the
middle one the middle yeah that's Mitch
that's the people on the call the five
who's Mitch Mitch is an old school wow
streamer he's been on Twitch a very very
long time I don't recall exactly what
his involvement in this call was so he's
he was at the time roommates with Miss
KF I think too or not roommates he lived
in his house yeah it's kind of funny
though that it's like all man Y and
basically all older than me talking
about me being so my wall I hate to say
it you know but it really is a boy club
in so many of these space just is yes
sir like when you when when how many
women were even in the Beast and seek
thing I think it was just two I think it
was her and Bella porch That's why I
could emphas emphasize so much with what
she said
because it's tough you can't hold that
sentiment of boy club against one person
individual I just wish people were a
little a little bit more considerate of
when it feels that way especially to
other minorities in a space you know
MH yeah so and then also finally is the
um how do I put this
it's Destiny Destiny's
Child uh Hassan's arch nemesis Destiny
Destiny's Child true I always forget
about that they [__] hate each other
apparently that's like old school lore I
I don't know anything about that lore
yeah I can't really follow it I just me
neither it's hard to follow it seems
like they hate each other as much as
like me and keemstar went through like
deep deep of like years and years you
know that's what it feels like it's in
the blood but I don't
know uh where did it go I [__] lost
the link again
damn oh I also want to uh Rec clarify
the call wasn't about me it was about
like essay allegations blah BL yeah I
was just brought up at some point
yeah so do we know who leaked it then
cuz there wasn't a lot of people on it I
think it was xqc or train I don't
remember who exactly but I'm pretty sure
it one of those two they're the two
scumbags that would do that yeah I feel
like they mentioned that at some point
in the call ex he posted this on his
channel he did well then it was x what
the [__] he posted this on his main
Channel called the leaked mkff called
the truth comes
out what sometimes I'm embarrassed of my
industry he
is holy [__] man holy [__] is there time
stamps at
least okay thank you thank you thank you
no oh [__] that's what Pokey does Pokey
is one of the most corrupt figures on
Twitch the only problem is that wait
real quick who's that other
voice is it that's asmin gold right I
think it is okay okay wait I'm confused
somebody's
streaming yes Destiny but then but
people can't hear the call yes but he
pauses and plays it whenever he wants so
these P these are just pictures of the
people in the call it's not them but his
audience can't hear what he's saying so
Destiny's streaming the video of the
recording he's just reviewing it oh he
on the
callusing it's on excc ripped got it he
ripped Destiny ripped the V I know it's
so [__] up dude what a dumbass pie of
[__] he is somebody please sue him
somebody please Sue that's what I'm say
like if you were to try to explain this
to someone try to explain this to some
like sometimes I hang out with my
friends and you know I'm going through
it I'm thinking about this stuff and
like they're normies they don't really
watch Twitch and they're like babe
what's going on like how do you explain
this to someone you
can that's how I constantly feel with
all my friends all right so let's see
here twitch thinks she's not replaceable
so that's why they listen there's two
people that that do right I think X
knows this right Nick Ms and poke man
those are the two people the only two
people twitch does not want to lose do
you understand the only two people Nick
Ms and Pokey man that's it
they believe they are not replaceable
everyone that they don't reign with they
believe are
repace just mad cuz you're trying to
Loki that's kind of like sweet in a way
or like flattering you know he's like
twitch just really cares about these two
creators I'm like that's nice but why is
there so much resentment in your voice
he [__] he's so bitter cuz he's like
dude I have to get my bag by doing like
shady stuff and like basically
indirectly like killing people maybe
that is the underlying he's like damn
but she just plays video
games and I I mean he could do the same
he really could no he couldn't nobody
would watch him play video games he's
not entertaining he might be actually
I've heard it to the contrary he might I
used to like him back in the days yeah
yeah he might be entertaining actually I
don't
know he's lost his ways all this stuff
can we let's focus on what you said you
said I
orchestrated that I train I want you to
listen to the scenario I woke up I
remember the whole day it was one of the
scariest days of my lives my best friend
in the whole world slick is getting
accused oh it was this whole thing I
remember that's what the call was about
okay yeah is there
more is that no but like that was I
think the
main so anyway here you responded the
train wreck that's kind of what I'm
getting so train came to my channel a
couple weeks ago and he gifted 100 subs
and I was like oh oh I'm just so
curious yeah did did you ever get any
Clarity on what happened there no he
just came gifted a 100 well you'll see
in the clip yeah all right here it
is I'm just so
curious why did you call me the most
corrupt person on Twitch I just want to
know and then we can move on I'm just so
you know cuz to me that was you know I
thought that was like a little
funny so I would love to hear your side
of it and then we can move on you
know but again when I speak generally
about
something
like I never mean to pass judgment on
individuals and I'm so sorry it came off
that way you
know I can be against gambling and still
get along with people who do that if
that makes sense or like gambling on
stream whatever did I say you're the
most corrupt can I have a clip
for context you can send whatever I
don't want to put you on oh he's
actually too so let me clarify he came
to my stream he gifted a bunch of subs
and I noticed this is something train
Rex does what a dor he's denying it some
sometimes yeah so for me I was like
there are so many times where I feel
like really not okay things have
happened and then once the person who
did the thing just like all of a sudden
wants to get over it I'm expected to get
over it right without addressing what
occurred so I was like right
I think he maybe wrote a message where
he's like oh you know like I just want
to move past the stuff that happened in
the past and I said okay but can you
just tell me like why did you say that
especially having it wind up being a
clip that like hundreds of thousands of
people see re-uploaded to his channel
yeah it was a lot and so you know I call
him out on that and he says did I say
you're the most corrupt can I have a
clip for context you can send whatever
don't want to put you on the spot and we
did pull up the clip and then his other
reply was something like oh I don't
really remember why I said that but you
can DM me and we can like talk about it
or something phony he was obviously so
angry and passionately why do you think
he did say that about you the most
corrupt person on Twitch
um I mean as you heard him say he was
saying
like twitch just doesn't want to lose
like these two people me and Nick MKS
which I don't want to say is true or not
but I do agree like you know twitch
values different creators for different
reasons right and so I think maybe
that's just something he didn't agree
with and maybe he thought like
I your fault maybe he thought that was
unfair maybe he thought he deserved
better wen't they doing rumors that like
you were sleeping with someone at twitch
or is that somebody else I've never
heard that oh [__] they were saying that
about somebody on Twitch weren't they
love yeah yeah I mean all women the
second they
like everyone gets accused of that it's
like the go to [__] [__] dud
twitch is a nightmare true I haven't
heard them specifically say that kind of
thing about me as far as I know but I
thought corrupt was a little bit crazy
just because I'm saying like hey can we
not gamble on the platform kids are
watching I mean corruption would be like
if if like uh the casinos in Vegas were
paying you to say that so that people
would go play there instead be
corruption right and I do want to say
that's something train would do yeah
like I was laughing about it in the clip
but in reality like what happened was
like really not funny and not easy to
deal with and I that was one of the
times being in this industry that I felt
like extremely unsafe and I avoided
industry events for a while because even
just standing up against gambling I got
so much harassment and then on top of
that to have like five of the most
popular male streamers in a private call
saying yeah no she's so corrupt I
couldn't even imagine what some of their
viewers might be thinking the lengths
that people might go to and so like I I
try to play things off a lot but in
reality like that [__] is not easy to
deal with and 100 gifted Subs is not
going to make me Overlook it either I
don't know if you want to say sorry say
that and then maybe we can move on the
thing is also like if people are
listening to a private call they might
assume that he's privy to cuz he didn't
exactly but there is nothing to explain
yeah yeah what a douche and then here's
another one this always
happens uh whenever any woman get in
trouble on internet for anything there's
always a post with like 880,000 likes So
Random so Sniper Wolf we've covered that
she's doc jacks films uh basically went
and took a picture of his front of his
house and posted it
yeah and this dude I don't know who he
is says my platform lets me get away
with anything starter pack which and and
again it's like clock work anytime a
girl gets into trouble there's this you
and her and being like look at these two
these are the two worst I mean to be I
feel like it's to be 100% with you I
don't even think these people hate me I
think I'm just really easy Twitter bait
honestly yeah after like the keemstar
the leafy the whatever there's just
always going to be some um people who
don't like me who are easy to clickbait
yeah 16 million views here's the thing
Sniper Wolf went to someone who she
didn't like house took a photo of the
front of his house showing his address
posted it to social
media okay and then they're saying also
just like Pokey man does
which seems I don't know what they're
comparing it to I think I'm just known
as like the twitch girl you know so a
lot of the twitch stuff will just be
like affiliated with me H yeah that's
crazy that's got to be really annoying
it is but I mean I'm glad that I at
least said something this
time cuz usually it's the kind of thing
that I would just like ignore Yeah
because sometimes it's not even worth it
right to say something I mean what can
you say the people that hate you are
going to hate you anyways and the people
that know otherwise or it's just so
predictable I see it so many times where
like there's just a group of [__]
dudes that just band together to harass
women and it happens on the internet all
the time these crusty [__]
incels I do want to say like I'm not
perfect I've 100% made mistakes but
those mistakes are either things that
I've already owned up to or also things
that um if I don't get banned for them
another male streamer will also not get
banned for them you know twitch will ban
people depending on like the severity
and the frequenc of something that you
do so sometimes people like she
accidentally showed like something
inappropriate on stream on you know and
I haven't gotten banned for that a lot
of male streamers haven't got and
obviously it was an accident so right I
remember people were angry which is
another interesting Theory they go I
wish twitch was more
punitive we but if it was your favorite
streamer you probably wouldn't wish that
cuz that's what they're advocating for
they're saying yo why didn't Pokey get
in trouble CU she accidentally showed
nudity
that's what we want we want more people
getting in trouble not less I don't know
T this is by the way I saw Mr be's
trending this [__] Mr Mr video watch
[Music]
[Laughter]
this music music music
Zach dude Vince McMahon that's who this
is right this dude has the best this is
such a good CLI he is such a character
he's a real sh in real life but he's
really the WWE I know him and he is the
best memes about him it's a powerful
moment that is a real good clip I'll say
that
much
[Music]
uh yeah I'm curious to see how the
what's the result of this I really
thought thing I thought he would just
either come out and be like Oh my
producers did this or something or he
would just say you know so like sorry
and move
on I was hoping for the sorry but I
thought it would be one of those two I
didn't think he would just message her
privately so easy to just just say like
it was an editing decision yeah for the
video I think people don't understand
how easy it is to
apologize I agree but I've I feel like
I've also been there so I get
it but still it's it's really easy to
it's painful but you got to let go
you're not perfect it doesn't matter if
thousand of people online think you're
perfect people mess up it's okay to say
that and the the more of an issue you
make it seem the more of an issue it
becomes right say my bad weird Paradox
is like you it's you feel horrible to
admit that you're wrong mhm yet it's
what everybody wants to see Y and it's
going to be the best outcome for you
yeah and but yet you yet it's you can't
do it cuz it's humbling yeah it hurts
ego we don't like that too much wine but
we got to let go of that why is he
hanging out with Benny Johnson what the
[__] is it I think also she's right that
it thinks growing up do yeah uh as a
person and
Creator what okay so Benny Johnson is
like a right ring provocator freak he
said hi me hi my name is Benny just
wanted to say thank you you've been an
inspiration for our YouTube content
whatever what he literally does
right-wing outrage
oh really yeah he's a piece of [__] oh
geez and then B says don't I know don't
I know you from ex political culture
stuff right you think he says X Out Loud
X I still say
Twitter yeah that makes this whole
exchange is [__] just based off of
that there's no way that Mr oh do I saw
you on X the only people that say x are
like Elon Fanboy conservative which
which that guy yeah he is he's so he
might say x x might he might be the only
person in the world that's a good point
he might an ex Oh weird um so anyway so
yeah you got compared to Sniper Wolf it
was pretty wild what's
new yeah two Wham let's go also I didn't
know but you had a spat with Boby who's
also a fixture on our show B who we call
box we call him Boby oh man oh man oh
man by the way I just want to give a
special shout out to keemstar who's the
lucky owner of 250 bobl plays dude he
stuck it to us he owned you dude funny
story we we did a gag where we bought a
bunch of his plushies cuz he needed like
500 the me the threshold to get it made
mhm and then he was he said some dumb
[__] I forget what but we're like [__]
it we're going to cancel our plushy
order and then keemstar I guess trying
to stick it to me bought them that's
greaten and that [__] ID that's such
good lore
wow he showed you dude I'm not going to
lie Bo blocks has been um very this this
is the steak headquarters that's so
good where it all
happened right there under that hey that
thatched roof not to be a buzz kill but
we did learn it's it's this Hut over
here that property is much more uh legit
yeah this one's more iconic though yeah
this is the iconic one but it it is
technically next door to this
so but yeah Bo blocks has been tweeting
about me since 2017 oh my God like a a
hot hot minute oh man I saw this tweet
is insane El you're gonna like this he
said so Pokey uploaded a video or did
you or someone did yeah you did or she's
eating a banana and she covers it
because she's like the internet's so
[__] crazy that me eating a banana so
the whole joke of the clip is like how
female streamers eat bananas and if you
play it I turn my camera off and turn it
back on quickly and the banana goes like
down and down and so I won't even like
actually eat it on stream cuz people are
cooky and will sexualize anything by the
way turn webcam off
yeah okay it just like slowly fully
disappears and come and becomes
shorter so there is the video it's a
little goof a gag a JK you know so Boby
said Pokey complains about Insel
Teenager sexualizing her and then
uploads this [__] to her YouTube channel
the [__]
yeah the
[__] you know what tipster would say to
him Zach cheers my dude no not that he
said he would say at
least at least I've seen what a vagina
looks
like Boby will never ever ever just
saying and experienced its gentle
caress that's more detailed than I
needed but Boby if you ever want to like
I don't know yeah you
probably what was his point that you're
just eating like he was oh he must have
you can read in the reply
yes yes yes so if you scroll down okay I
[__] up here I then delete it [__] I
saw this on my short feed and thought I
was one of those weird Pokeman as hop
type videos from a clip Channel which
also like what is he talking about what
kind of Clips what's your algorithm
looking like exactly sir I personally
never seen these videos Sir what do you
mean then I was surprised that it was
from Pokey yourself so I tweeted about
it without watching the full short I'm
going to leave the Tweet up because I
don't want to hide from criticism
recovering up my Stakes I have an issue
with tweeting too impulsively and
getting into trouble I don't hate Pokey
I was just annoyed at the idea that she
would play into what she speaks out
against which did not [__] happen
just again to clarify dude audio is
slightly delayed he should really how
can you not even watch like a 17sec
short before tweeting about it that's
not trigger fingers that's like Twitter
fingers like take a breather take a
breather he does come from the camp of
keemstar Journalism so oh get me as far
away from that camp as possible please
yeah stop sorry BBY it had to be said f
um so there's that do we have any other
um he has the best sound bites though
Jimmy oh we got to do the dock
clip D
brick Oh yeah let's talk to my mom let's
bring her up is she in the the waiting
room happy
[Music]
birthday it's my
mom's so it's my mom's birthday today
I need to do some
[Applause]
calculations oh wow she's old these nuts
she turning
[Music]
42 it looks great though
mhm said I'm here it's a nightmare it's
a nightmare it's maybe she will be in do
something well in our in our text change
she said I'm here but she's not so give
her just a minute here she's not there
she's not
there she's not
there uhhuh okay still just standing by
here all right well let me talk to fidus
while we
wait okay hold on just just a moment so
anyway we were we were discussing really
heavy duty kind of ideas in my podcast
about
intellectualism and uh I was just
telling fidus here basically
that you know in
life a lot of the times people go out
into the world and they say what can I
do how can I make this mine but what
they're really missing and FY is not if
you think this is interesting right here
I got it on okay go
ahead
happy birthday happy birthday happy
birthday you look beautiful do you want
to say your age or
no I'm 68 years young today wow wow
congratulations who wow you look great
huh
true and I was thinking how beautiful
you girls look
today thank you girly thank you play We
love that about you Donna you're always
so um Mom happy birthday I just wanted
to say that also I wanted to say save
your takes about Israel and Gaza for uh
Thanksgiving
dinner trust me please was a joke but
it's it's not it's not good to to joke
about it right now yeah oh were you
gonna joke about it it it was a joke oh
my God that's even
worse she she told me the joke it's not
the worst joke it's not that bad yeah
but you tell it I told her it's up to
her but maybe it sounds like Dan gave
you the green
light I mean it's it's a very it's a
very mom joke let's go ahead Mom let's
hear the
joke did I really say it oh my God
you're good Dan heard it I think you're
good
Dogo well I was just saying that you
know the whole
Palestinian uh Egyptian Arab problems
with Israel it all stemmed from one man
Abraham because he couldn't keep his his
pants
zipped
Abraham cuz Abraham he was the wor Jew
right well I was he Jew he was an
Israelite I the first Jew that's that's
the lore right yeah I guess I guess all
the the yeah I guess he was the first
Jew because then if he so then if he
didn't have SE who did he have sex with
well he had he had a um he had sex with
um his wife's maid oh oh wait his wife's
maid yeah and then yada yada yada you've
got the war between uh Hamas and Israel
that's crazy it's a whole family
Dynamic I did not know the Lord blame
man for everything so Abraham down
Abraham started a trained reaction
Judaism was started then Christianity
and then M uh Islam and we are saying if
we're looking back in time and looking
at you Abraham and
saying maybe if he would just maybe if
he wouldn't never [__] the The Nanny
then maybe it would just be Utopia on
Earth we wouldn't even need all these
religions right you know I well I'm not
gonna say anything I just there was
peace at one point there was a Utopia at
one point there was I mean people used
to worship um idols and they started you
know saying that they prayed to one one
God
and the whole thing is just silly yeah
okay it's it's just you know if you read
the
Bible the uh the in Genesis it's it's
all aun dysfunctional family drama
familiar familiar topics
mhm so Mom go ahead do you have a
birthday request or wish for everybody
watching well last time when I blew out
the candles and I wished for peace on
Earth everyone uh got mad cuz I said it
out loud also clearly did not
work clearly God granted the opposite
well maybe it's gonna take some time
that's true fair yeah I don't know I
just you know I just want everyone to
get along and be well and no no milked
uh
wishes what's that no milkweed wishes
oh milk weed wishes you know what I I
still have uh I've I still have uh
monarch butterflies fluttering around my
backyard I think I'm GNA start cutting
down my milkweeds because they they need
to head out to the beach oh shoot oh you
made it too you made it too cozy for
them in your backyard I think so I gotta
I gotta kick them out kick them out of
the
nest so I will say one thing I I I um
one wish that I think I'm going to
fulfill myself you know the boys are
going to go
trick-or-treating and I think I would
like to join the kids this
year it look like it was so much fun
even though it's far
for you'll never see the boys happier
than than y oh my go it's the best day
of their life basically oh I know and
this is going to be Bruce's first
Halloween he's going to freak out he was
pushed in stroller last year I don't
think so um I don't think he came with
us last year he didn't no I think it was
just said he was pushing this stroller
it was like past his bedtime but now
he's going to love it and he loves candy
too I'll say that oh my God they both
have such sweet sweet tooths I would
love to go with I just think it's a
blast to see their little
faces let's do it we're we're all
dressing up as dinosaurs I don't know if
you want to join in we can get you one a
dinosaur oh my God we got pretty cool
dinosaur outfits you want for family
photo all right listen happy birthday
thank you my loves and I will see you on
Sunday see you on Sunday
bye happy birthday happy
[Applause]
birthday
oh
the fade away so thank you to my
mom oh [__] he's having the same problem
you were talking about okay hold on we
see okay that was that was pretty good
that was pretty fast bye
Donna she's still there yeah no she's
getting better at it that so cute so
let's see we got oh let's do the dubric
thing I guess then duri yeah dubri so
dubri as you know what did he do the
David variety yes I haven't heard about
him in a minut he's he's become quite
controversial well I thought he just
didn't post anymore he's on Snapchat
yeah he's only like no more YouTube no
more Tik Tok no more Instagram TI Tok no
he's making a ton of money from what I
understand on Snapchat dude I don't know
how that happens yeah but go on so
anyway he has never really addressed all
the controversies in a in a good way mhm
he almost killed
Jeff who's not a big fan of his anymore
clearly so here this clip was sent to
me they're they're in the middle of a
lawsuit of some sort right Jeff I don't
know what's the status on that lawsuit
actually it's true David would probably
be but I don't know what's going on
right me neither isn't that stuff like
public though if you look it up yes it's
yeah yeah it is public
curious so here's a clip of three Vlog
Squad members
uh Carly I know who Aaron is I don't
know who Carly is Carly and Aaron do uh
they're like besties do they have a
podcast they have some sort of show they
were the they were on uh Alex's podcast
before she went to the Colt potluck if
you remember that oh yeah
yes yes that whole
story so the who's the guy in the back's
also a vlog Squad guy isn't he Matt King
is he King is he the
king he's King K Matt that's his name
for sure I wanted to say thank you to
jewels who sent this to me H
fresh thank you Jules all right here we
go it's true David would probably be
arrested for like kidnapping capturing
his friends and loing them in a basement
and I think real I think realistically I
could see like doing an animal thing and
something going wrong and he got gets in
trouble for it yeah but instead of
animal just people yeah or something or
like hurting somebody cuz remember the
Jonah thing I mean he probably would
have got in trouble for that or was that
would that be Jonah's fault what do you
mean cuz he's like filming it when Jonah
did the I don't think no cuz Jonah did
it on his own yeah Jona wouldn't Su dude
they're insane like the way that they've
Del M
what oh
okay um the way that they're like the
coldin is coming out right here the way
that they're like oh no no that's not
David's fault uhhuh Jonah did it Jonah
was riding the motorcycle I to me it
felt more like they were talking about
technicalities they are yeah like no he
wouldn't Sue so David would never get in
trouble yeah right let's hear Let me
hear it again what do you mean cuz he's
like filming it when Jonah did the I
don't think no cuz Jonah did it on his
own yeah Jonah wouldn't Sue oh but it
would be a real test of friendship to
figure out who would sue he wouldn't
yeah the serious
of is I find really interesting not
getting at all well can can you sue
someone for doing that if you like
willingly are like I'm going to ride
this bike I don't think that I don't
think that either but like I was when
the aligator almost bit my hand I was
like what would I have done if it like
tore up my hand but I feel like I could
have done something with that right
since he put it on me and I didn't no
you like agre did that happen or is she
talking he brought so many wild animals
into his Vlogs is she talking a baby
bear no I think that actually happened
wait hold the phone the lizard people
hold on let me go back he put his
friend's hand in a crocodile's mouth
someone for doing that if you like
willingly are like I'm going to ride
this bike I don't think that I find I
can look for the crocodile when the
alligator almost bit my hand I was like
what would I almost bit her hand oh my
God yeah and wow dude he's so crazy it's
like I wasn't watching the time when all
this was going on but like I was never
really into his Vlogs and the one guy
that I knew that was into his his
Vlogs red flag no
buo no good if you know you know no
buo I have done if it like tore out my
hand I know a guy who was really into
his Vlogs huge fan of his
actually and nothing he's a really good
guy oh that's nice he's not here right
now but I feel like he's a really sweet
that's kind of what David played into
all the time the will something terrible
happen or he used it yeah and what now
that we know from this horrific accident
that happened on the on the excavator
that he has no safety
Notions no which in my opinion is the
least you can do when you're like a
multi- gajillionaire and you're using
your friends for
Content that's what so hard for me to
understand like it's like it's the bare
minimum yeah at least do that or hire
someone to it underscores a real actual
problem that's existing on YouTube which
is right there's this huge blind spot
for creators who are have become as
popular and as outreaching and as
wealthy as some of these networks and
production
companies yet they don't follow any of
the procedures that they've established
over many decades of of doing it no
safety protocols the truth is though
they got to start getting sued that's
how this [__] gets established hold the
phone here's a [__] video of him
putting his friends
night what the [__] she's a big ass
[__] alligator I've been talking
about David do for years at this point
and I haven't seen
this well he has like a wild animal guy
who brings these animals but it's still
crazy let's see all right we're going to
take the blindfold off in three 2
1 what the oh my God Is that real
[__] way no it's not real but it
looks real doesn't it are you
kidding gator in the
room that's nut can you really do that
he was just acting I mean it does not
seem safe in my opinion at least there's
a person but I have no idea how they're
trained is this you can't train an
alligator [__] alligator like who's
no it's what kind of person is the did
Casey text back oh good idea yeah I want
I want to I've been wanting to watch
this documentary no Ethan as someone who
did how good is it it's okay I will say
that un oh you watch it too yeah okay
unfortunately it's nothing like new I
see it was more of like storyline
following I do Wonder though if people
outside the you know influence of
YouTube who like I already know
everything about him right how they
would be impacted by this I see I think
it would because he's so
popular to the point that it's like like
Ethan said like you could be outside of
like the YouTube knowled kind of like
how Netflix does all those documentaries
on like is it firefest or whatever yeah
the things that happen that would be
interesting yeah but for us who know
everything you I
see I mean they had a huge falling out
from it yeah understandable anyway back
to uh endangering the lives of his
friends in 3 2 1 take it off it's for
sure not cool for the
[Music]
animal people screaming and whooping
like Just For Your
Entertainment Mr Castro are you ready
yeah I'm assuming the only way that they
quote unquote made it safe they probably
just fed him a shitload of food before
he goes in there oh but I mean that's a
good point yeah still not
foolproof let's go appar almost spit
that girl I want to see that is this the
Handler I food trip Christmas time let's
go I
don't why are they doing that 2 1
go you know what in the Philippines we
got this
one yeah like does he think it's fake I
think he thinks it's fake
yeah he thinks it's he's alive cuz the
worst part is where David is cuz if this
guy is alive he will CAU David but he's
not alive he's not alive yeah cuz he
alive he's Alive's alive no no no no no
no no that could have been so bad dude
he put I feel like as soon as he sees
the guy P you got to tell him no he's
real yes stink when I saw that no it's
also like when he touched his arm yes
like yeah no as soon as you see cut cut
cut the tape put let's put a dangerous
predator in a situation with people who
don't know anything about it don't know
safety procedures even F tell them it's
fake is nuts that's crazy you didn't
know he was
alive ate your family I love poking it
cuz you thought it was fake oh this
thing I've seen it in
Philippines I'm so sorry s with
me watching make sure you like And
subscribe tweet me at David Dober guys
this is the holidays I'm making all the
merch 20% off and what did everybody
want to tell the camera show your pee
the cheer no Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas this oh man if V this couldn't
get better o
dumb wishing you a merry Christmas this
this is a beautiful video ran this last
year can't wait till next year hi I'm
Josh man that's a hell of a video video
you know about the Dom stuff of course
yeah okay just making sure so that was
that was don't worry I
know that was a perfect video was there
a part where he puts a hand in the mouth
I did not that was it I think the last
last video in the oh there's another
video there's multiple yeah oh
God he's done the the crocodile gag a
few
times should I watch the second or third
one third one is the one uh with the
girl right with the monkey in the THB
okay very
good my
god oh dude wait hold the [__] it
cuts right when it's next to her hand
too dude it was very first of all that's
a baby so don't tell me that it's well
trained I doesn't know what's happening
look how close he's to biting her look
at that wait do you think that was the
girl in the Tik Tok clip it was I I no
wait this is the perfect screenshot cuz
she's like what if it bit my hand a
screenshot about to B her hand yeah can
we screenshot this imagine that just
Chomps off a finger to uh here's the
also the thing is like he's had so many
Close Encounters you would think like
I'm so [__] lucky I'm so happy to be
honest I feel like in his mind he must
have started to feel like Invincible
yeah true especially with that kind of
attention and validation your ego goes
through the roof real quick
true I mean and then this scene really
[__] me
[Music]
up I don't like this stuff the
alligators are so cool and like just to
see them being used like that just for
stupid YouTube videos I don't like any
wild animal content stuff anymore yeah
if you go frame by frame on that
alligator one by the hand you can see it
like uh make contact
jrh NBR oh oh oh my God it just misses
no it keeps it touches it you see boom
Oh
crazy I don't know if is it possible
that like a bite from a baby wouldn't be
as I mean it would look at his teeth I
have no idea an adult one no it wouldn't
it wouldn't he probably wouldn't like
bite your hand off but he definitely
would [__] you up yeah night there's no
question that would be stitches that
would be emergency room you know what I
mean I'm looking up baby alligator bites
how is this new I do not like it I can't
believe this I've never seen this stuff
look at those teeth
youa I actually really love alligators
dude so
swim dude this freeze frame is nuts so
you want some [__]
tee y so anyway she was telling the
truth here oh my God but I feel like I
could have done something with that
right since he put it on me and I didn't
no you like agreed to do it okay Aaron
you got to chill she's laying on the
floor with her face covered she's so
deep in the
cold mindset it's crazy you can see how
every response is
like H I don't know protect David yeah
protected so fun you agreed to do it
laying blind footed on the
floor so F glory to our master
but I didn't really I thought it was a
dog he said it was a p oh he lied to her
he said it's a that's why they're always
blindfolded and stuff it's always a but
you can't agree to something you don't
know that's some ghoul Behavior Aaron I
have to say that she agreed to that
telling that to her face it's too deep
maybe she was speaking like legally I
don't know what the legalities are if
someone does it I can't imagine that
that's legal yeah it's definitely it
would still not be okay she thinks it's
a dog and it's an lying 100% would not
be okay then I think she clearly has a
problem with it the way she the fact
that she's even bringing it up makes me
think that she's been thinking about how
crazy that was yeah Aaron doesn't have a
problem
though I think if if David accidentally
did something without you even knowing
like we were at coella and he was
playing around with the sunscreen and
like a lighter like trying to like oh
yeah freak people out with it like you
remember in Coachella when he was
walking around with like a can of uh
aerosol A flammable parasol and he was
blasting huge Fireballs in everyone's
face
Jesus and if he set my face on fire yeah
that's
cool what he said yeah he said he said
he said his face on fire not a big deal
the usual he he agreed to
it yeah you never you never your face
never been not the asking for
it and if he set my face on fire he pay
for your literally nobody my God stop
justifying
everything nobody he immediately comes
in with the pay for your medical which
by the way is a part of Jeff's lawsuit
yeah he he didn't cover yeah that blew
my okay on one hand it did shock me cuz
I'm like you have so much money this
would be an easy pay but then I realized
oh his lawyers probably said if you pay
for it it means you're like admitting
guilt right yeah th% and you still
didn't I would be like even if legally
it's a bad thing to do humanly I
freaking need to well if that was his
lawyers yeah if that was his lawyers
advice like look there's there's smart
lawyers and there's dumb [__]
lawyers sometimes a smart lawyer is
going to look at a situation and look at
it holistically and not just be blinded
by the law cuz if it cuz that was
terrible advice if the lawyer was like
because there's also public perception
to think about exactly not only like the
on the paper so like it if he would have
just taken care of Jeff none of this
would have happened it wouldn't have
snowballed as much as it did and look at
this this Frame is even scarier
frankly
okay that's the scariest one let's
continue and if he set my face on fire
notice how nobody even reacts to that
this man just no it's okay he would have
paid for your funeral don't worry yeah
someone in chat said that I can't yoink
it he had life
insurance don't worry he would take care
of your family yeah I'll pay for your
kid
college with it like and if he set my
face on fire pay for your medical yeah
pay for my medical and just take care of
me for the rest of my life yeah he he
wouldn't what if my face was deformed
and melted and I had to walk around with
like a mask like Phantom of the Opera
for the rest of my life he'd cover your
medical he spot you on that he'd spot
you for that he'd spot he' get you a
sick mask he would cut off his face and
give it to he would get you a sick Tesla
mask Matt's like I'm
good so interesting I wonder what the
legalities are even like the steo thing
when he jumped in the pool I was like
train professional like he's but
everyone there was like I don't want to
like be involved in this cuz like
yeah you and me walk we I don't know who
she is but she's the only one with a
[__] brain right now it's actually
pretty impressive that she's breaking
through the veil of cess and actually
speaking some sense to these two well
you know actually during coid Aaron got
married and the Vlog Squad the
Friendship had like a a separation
because they refused to get vacine so
they disinvited them which I thought was
cool wait who didn't get a vaccine Zayn
didn't get a vaccine let me see who who
didn't end up going wait they had a
falling out with some Vlog Squad MERS
because they wouldn't get vaccinated oh
yeah oh I want to know who wouldn't get
vaccinated
okay but was Aaron one of them no Aaron
was the one getting married oh was her
wedding yeah got it got it we did got it
got
it backyard I was like worried if you
got Co though David would cover
it it's not a big deal like I don't want
to see him like hit the ground or
something yeah yeah super interesting
yeah wow took me down quite a rabbit
hole
too there it is thank you jwes and shout
out to David do is there any way to see
what his snapchot stories are I'm so
curious I'm curious too yeah I never
took uh can we look at it i' I've
browsed it briefly it's just a bunch of
random [__] let's see David do Snapchat
um can you browse it on I don't know I
think you can let's see this is snapped
I don't understand what I'm looking at
where's the spotlight the left there
which one is it or
stories no you went off you need to fck
go back my Boomer is coming out I never
used this platform I think click on one
of those like the one on the left yeah
there's arrows on the left probably cuz
I want to I want to see when was his
last
post cuz it says
Thursday I'm sorry I just can't imagine
taking a photo of a hot girl and then
captioning that wait could you just pose
real quick
setting up for Halloween festivity and
she's like holding a can of what is that
it's it's a sponsor I'm sure of it
Celsius oh that would make S here's
another one oh yeah always so random
dude what a little [__] sneako he has
like at least a 100 maybe 200 posts I
like thaty the past 24 hours or maybe
yeah like a bunch this is it and uh it's
all with hot girls in them when did he
turn into like look at the per Celsius
ads what the [__] watch really good I'll
tell you wait I think oh never mind I
was going to say I feel like this might
not even be him filming it I can't oh is
there no audio wait there is audio right
cuz you oh my god see that's what I'm
talking about that was actually really
good trying to do his laugh yo why is I
didn't realize he was like doing a um yo
I hope these girls are getting paid at
least I hope they're getting paid I
think
I don't think
he oh yes what's up D I mean nobody on
the vog got paid no I don't think he
pays
people Jason's been live get paid by
being in his presence come on baby come
on guys just someone else here yes okay
so Dave here's what
happened yeah unfortunately that's kind
of his whole life oh my God that's
shocking too no I don't think they were
working with Celsius though there's no
evidence said that was a undisclosed
sponsor
yeah just moving on to the next money
making game there's no way to
know I've never watched these
interesting yeah and someone just gave
me a lion what's a lion a lion is like
one of the highest gifts you can get I
think it's like 30,000 points shut the
[__] yeah up 50,000 points I will also
show David do right here he's standing
next to me Jason there's like white
stuff coming out the side of your mouth
cuz you're yelling so much okay I know
what do you want me to do you're like a
soccer
coach wow and what poor Jason his his
content does horrible like he the juice
is not helping him what's his last name
Nash Nash Let's
see why is Jason feeling like he needs
to hang out with him I don't know dude
it's literally the yo guys before I need
to let you know that I'm going that a
60y old no I'm kidding I don't know how
old he is don't say he's 38 though he's
older than me I just want people to know
that it's okay to hang up the camera at
one point you know 50 this like you
don't got to keep doing this he's not
going to go do like an insurance he's
not going to go door to door selling
knives you could do anything I don't
know what else is he going to do yeah so
I mean and all the dicks writing he does
for David and he's getting 30,000 views
on his video after 2 weeks like holy
[__] that's rough that is rough I'm
Ward's pulling better numbers nice well
Tom Tom W's a legend hold on back it up
I said he's pulling more numbers
yeah man I don't know this you guys
should do a Snapchat Deep dive one day M
do you know like the Snapchat what
happens what do you have to give T
100,000 are Joo siwa yeah yeah she had a
whole
controversy on Snapchat cuz she kept
pretending to be pregnant and apparently
oh yeah the nzen speculate that there
you know she has a Snapchat deal too and
apparently your Snapchats do more if
they're related to pregnancy so she just
kept joking about yeah that and probably
things like hot girls and whatever else
right and and she just kept pretending
to be pregnant in the most like click
bity way that's why there's that one
meme photo of her laying down and her
belly someone needs to pull it up I
can't even explain always like you know
how Snapchat the the thumbnail of the
person's story is always their last snap
of the day JoJo always ended it with a
pregnancy snap so that the thumbnail was
always so like sometimes it was like a
like a room of like baby clothes or like
her holding her belly or like looking
for stuff yeah like P team boy or team
girl that would be the caption all the
time so odd
no no no no she's joking about it or
she's really pretending though I'm not I
don't understand oh I think it's just to
get just to get Quicks dude Snapchat's
[__] weird
yeah baby clo dude what the the
hell it's way more uh oh my god oh yeah
no there's another one like implying it
but this is just straight up like oh
yeah I'm pregnant I'm buying stuff for
my baby right now well I mean what else
does team boy team girl me yeah dude
that one the one on the right became
such a meme oh my God so she was being
paid a lot of money probably this that
CPM I've heard is absolutely insane on
Snapchat yes it's just crazy She's So
Young uh just to look at Jason again for
a moment this is man is probably 50 or
close to it and look at his this man's
kitchen floor I mean there's just no
reason for that dude this is the same
his kids Liv it's just it's it's just
now is not the time my friend is it
crazy that I feel bad for him I feel bad
for him no it's not crazy at all I
definitely feel that for Jason I feel
like the way David views him versus the
way he views David is just like world's
apart I I think Jason interally and in
private with his close family or
whatever I think that he has some weird
stuff coming up here hold on like wait
really what is it it's kind of
well just take it off the screen is it
is there
nudity not really but hold on I'll show
you I think Jason has a lot of
resentment to
him I think I think maybe deep down but
I don't know I see love in his eyes I
really do he's like d daddy David you
know I don't
know man I don't know yeah all right
well whatever so anyway I'm I mean
fascinating stuff true it's F oh I don't
know if you knew this but Jason's wife
he just got married to this young this
young girl I don't know how old she what
but she's young this is her she's the
girl from the Ben Affleck meme it's me
do you remember the Ben Affleck meme
which one he he why did you unag he was
yes that's her I mean come on put it out
paid actress or she released it no
they're really
married but she's the she's the I can't
imagine seeing that and being I don't
know I don't why did you I'll stop
talking now why did you unmatch me match
me it's
me this is
her yeah that's her yeah it is her so
this girl is now married to Jason that
is wild she unmatched that is a crazy
crossover yeah the the unmatching Ben
for Jason is is uh not that I'm a huge
Ben Affleck simp and seeing his back
tattoo is definitely makes it rough you
know but but that being said I think
probably that would be
a why did you unmatch me play the whole
thing I want to hear it it's me that
video let me find a different Source cuz
that one why did you unmatch music put
under it it's me it's me the wa he's so
awesome yeah I was wondering on Snapchat
is something else uh pretty low on the
active users scale compared to other
stuff where does their money come from
that's my
question wait Twitter is low wonder if
they're going to run out of it because
they're just cuz they're paying out the
Wu
yeah cuz I don't know how does it pay
for that how does it pay for itself yeah
I don't know they must have huge
investors they're just Capital uh head
or Capital Investments Angel Investors
like that's terrible Roi though it has
to stop at some point well they these
guys they no you're right it has to stop
at some point but these these Silicon
Valley investors they're always looking
for like I'll put in a million and they
make a billion but I hate that
Snapchat will choose somebody like drick
to put all their money
behind instead of like actually create
something more cool with their
platform I've heard about those deals
they're not that selective with who it's
more about uh
connections there's like one guy who's
kind of giving out the deals that's so
[__] true some creators have helped
other creators get these like extremely
lucrative Snapchat deals being like Oh
okay just like include this person
that's that's exactly what it is man you
know I don't really network no one's
really filtering yeah that that's
exactly
right I hate that why would she post
this so
unnecessary why did you unmatch me it's
me
dude like what did he do
get better every time what did he do to
deserve that NAD or whatever nav why did
he do that cuz she un mashed him she
thought it was
fake it's me I wonder poor Ben Affleck
he's out there just trying to you know
make connections and everyone thinks
it's fake Ben afflick listen he ended up
with J why did you unch me it's me are
they still together I think so they got
back together I yeah they're back oh
yeah it's been a good time Ben is back
Oh you mean like they're hard back
they're hard launch yeah they're
together hard launch yeah they haven't
they haven't broken up since then do
they have kids and
[__] I know he's got kids with Jennifer
Gardner whatever he has kids with
Jennifer Gardner and she has uh other
kids
but anyway this is kind of surprising
Facebook is crushing it YouTube shout
out number two WhatsApp is that even a
social media I don't know what is the
metric here what is it showing it's
users uh in million ions so Facebook has
3 billion active monthly users we use
WhatsApp for our like communication but
um it it has like a whole another side
to it of like pages that you can follow
huh yeah you don't know about this no
I'm I used WhatsApp is very very
popular do but mainly in like Eastern
countries yeah in Israel it's huge and
people all kinds of groups for stuff you
know many International artists also use
whatspp to like keep in touch with their
fans they have these big like pages and
the reason I started using it is because
you can call International free
basically instead of having to get like
a international package dude the top
four social medias are all owned by
Facebook it's so scary how is Facebook
number one people seriously dude
Facebook wait what what do you mean the
top four Facebook owns WhatsApp and
Instagram no they own Instagram and
WhatsApp she's saying not YouTube though
three of the top
oh
yeah that's nuts yeah that is nuts
that's not
cool Zach when is enough enough man you
already own half of Hawaii leave some
for the natives I'm the me
Chef uh okay there it is I'm making
Meats now we're learning we're we're
learning we're growing we're evolving if
you asked me I I would have said that
Facebook is dying or something but yeah
I mean I think it is it had its first
quarter ever where they had net less
signups I think that was the first time
it happened
recently but they are so popular with
Boomers and just around the world it's
bananas man it's
bananas
um oh
dude you're not there you're not
there when you're nightmare it's a
nightmare it's a nightmare
when you're not
there not there you're not there great
song Ethan this is my song that's it's
on my first EP called nightmares
nightmares my stage name is um sleep wow
check me out on iTunes Ely that allam
platform be all over my spoy possible
opportunity yeah copyrighted
registered and I am
litigious in case anyone's watch
watching that might think about ripping
me off uh we don't have much time left
but there's one more thing I want to
do God that went by fast I was just
going to say so fast it's 4 20 Blaze
hour so yo how long 3 hours has it been
three how long have we going mhm 3 hours
there's no literal
way it's
420 we WRA the drama up and we smoke it
man we wrap Mr be up in a in a joint and
we blaze
it two in the nose three in the mouth BL
it
brother
oh cuz the ganja come
down like Mana from heaven
now yeah so join with
me
that's right it's Ethan the roster the
prophet of the good old relig I can't
why do you guys encourage me to do it
yeah why do you sorry sorry cut the
music cut it off I have a feeling this
is not going to age well dude you know
in 10 years people can you believe he
did that that's what and they know that
and they encourage it not dude not cool
dude it's not
cool we discovered that it sounded like
Sean Stevens was saying Zion and then
Zion Oh if I think about Zion I'm cool
right and then so I asked uh I asked
Zach to play some reggae music and hit
me with the Zion zionists are the
problem with the world
man I tell you Zionism is going to be
the end of a different thing it's a
different but we don't have to get into
it Zan is a different look of concern to
the yeah you shouldn't have gone there
with
me yo Jimmy's repping the N Jimmy's wild
he's a good one that is a wild child
right there he's good yeah does he know
that the fidus was fake do you think or
does he think no I think he thinks that
it's real yeah I think he did too
somebody in the office for real I do
think so as well uh but you know he is
he is an intent listener so it's hard to
tell so there's a
um there is a a a cringe uh pickup
artist another one yeah that's trodden
ground Joe Rogan thinks people who
celebrate their birthdays are quote
gay I want to hear that okay I may have
I may have uh G you may have embellished
that I may have extrapolated some
meaning but here I'll let you be the yes
please we'd love to hear where' it
go uh
z z man no more people people in the
chat are talking about this uh this eel
pit thing do you know what they're
talking about oh yeah I have a whole eel
pit segment should we do that yeah do
all people have been really wanting the
eel pit segment and what is it it's just
a girl in on Tik Tok she has a literal
eel pit in the basement of her house and
she just has eels there right it's a
girl I thought it was I don't know who I
don't know it's a guy I don't know
anything about this eel pit I don't know
even know what you're talking about
anyway here's Joe Rogan who's taking the
alpha thing maybe too far I don't know
you guys be the judge they're always
trying to ones up each other with how
alpha they are okay it's true you know
what's even weirder people give a [__]
about their birthday shut your mouth
yeah you know oh it's my birthday if I
guess I get if it's girls for some
reason that doesn't annoy me when dudes
get really excited about their birthday
come on bro yeah I'm not your mom your
mom dude are you like for
real like imagine being friends with Joe
Rogan like hey it's my birthday
I'm not your [__] mom bro can you
shut your [__] mouth [__] tell save
that for your mom I don't care didn't
ask don't care Lally you trying to lift
some weights or no only only ladies only
women only females care about their
birthday their birth honestly happy to
be a lady then me I love my birthday
birthdays are great for many of us it's
all we have true we get one [__] day
where we can be you know we were almost
just wiped out by a pandemic [__] is
going on everywhere all over the world
and I can't be happy cuz I was born on
this day that's crazy that's it it's all
we
have one more time cuz I love it you
know what's even weirder people give a
[__] about their birthday shut your
mouth shut your mouth you know oh it's
my birthday if I guess I get if it's
girls for some reason that doesn't annoy
me when dud you should examine why yeah
let's unack I don't agree with him on M
but his overall point I got to say I'm a
birthday hater what just I don't want to
he list you're allowed to well hold on
is forcing you to be excited about your
birthday hold on I have question you
know I don't want to hear what do you
mean I don't want to hear about it like
what does that mean I mean what you went
around the Sun one more time
congrats wow I thought I was the one
with the bad takes just bringing the
mood down
dude everything it's a little bit extra
special just one day of the year yeah
what's everybody's gentle with you don't
like birthdays you don't like doing
acknowledging other people's birthdays I
like that to congrat it's like a day
where you are the holiday that day yeah
you know you're special for one damn day
Dan iose I didn't like birthdays until I
had a good birthday maybe you just need
a really good birthday you know just
haven't had a goodth what was your good
birthday um they converted you man it
wasn't until I was like 19 or something
but I just like hung out with friends
and we did something oh you had fun yeah
was the first time yeah my birthdays the
years before I don't know something
always
happened something but when you have a
few good birthdays you're like this
isn't that
bad so Dan is co-signing that birthdays
are for gay people only I not
I'm honestly the gays deserve it you had
to do the carve out for girls I I am I
am equal opportunity hater here girls
birthday boys birthday you know what I
respect that I respect that can we do a
pride minute please all right Dan I'll
make sure not to invite you I can't wait
I for one can't wait to celebrate Love's
birthday on Monday
thank love I don't want to hear about it
and I'm not his mother shut your mouth
you guys are going to hear about it sh
sh just call your mom or
something you think I'm your aunt what
do you expect me to mail you a
check can I can we do a pride minute for
all the birthday
lovers guys we have 1 minute to
celebrate our our identity we have spent
a lifetime in the closet hiding in fear
of the religious the judgmental
theapatheticfish
SL how are you going to be Gary ve and
pour some milk into a coffee that says
be yourself and I got new that's all
we're trying to do is our trans people
gay people by people everybody in the
Spectrum the beautiful rainbow it's
outrageous who else do we hate for just
being born the way they are shame on you
world and we're not it's despicable and
we're standing out for the light we are
looking to the clouds we are looking to
the heavens we are looking to all of our
contemporaries and we are saying we are
here and we are powerful uhhuh and we
are ourselves yeah and pride minute is
about looking forward to the time when
we won't have to have pride minutes
anymore we won't have to do this we
won't have to fight for our rights all
right time's up all right back in the
closet freaks yeah I'm not gay no more I
don't want to hear it I don't want to
hear about your birthday gays back in
the CL it I wish I could see the rest of
this clip I want to know what the other
guy said was it a yes man moment or was
someone like dead every time they agreed
I'll I'll play it again he goes that's
true every guy ever on Joe Rogan that's
true sure for sure dude and a lot of
ladies a lot of people on his show are
just like uhhuh yes daddy anything you
say I don't know I remember when he had
Miley Cyrus I think yeah Andre Rogan and
the comments were so not cute I never
watched another one ever again yeah
super dude yeah I mean it seemed like
everybody who commented did not listen
to 2 minutes of the podcast cuz her
story is so interesting and empowering
and they were all just like why does she
sound like that why does she look like
that and I was like bye G she's actually
really cool now she is she's had a whole
for a very long time all her interviews
all her like Media stuff have been so
interesting to reflect on CU she has had
one of the most interesting come ups and
one of the most unique lives ever so to
hear from her is really cool in my
opinion these male dominated spaces
online are seriously like just the worst
man lately specifically but here's Joe
Rogan getting co-signed on the birthday
hit really excited about their birthday
come on bro come on bro come I'm not
your mom it's true you we it's true true
true have you seen bread in shs yes man
compilation it's really fun oh I love
that one um I just want up that must be
crazy and say that I ran a poll here
pull up of our audience of if they care
about birthdays and almost a full third
of our audience agrees with me so I am
getting voice to the voiceless that's a
bad I think that maybe it's missing an
option of like I don't care either way
you know cuz I think there's a lot of
people in the
middle why don't you you should care
about other people's birth
birthdays you don't want to make other
people feel special ask them we don't
care you don't care about other people's
birthday why don't you care you don't
like
people do you hate in general yeah yeah
I'm
Joker you an anarchist a real Joker
brain D you showed up to my birthday and
he gave me a gift was that torture of
course come on I'm not going I'm
psychopath I'm not going to knock to
your birday sound like a hypocrite
I'm just I'm bending to society's whims
you
know um ah this is my look at that a
third of our audience though that's
first of all that's a lot of people
dude hold on hold on hold on that's a
blowout I'm sorry that's not close
that's a no obviously most yeah I'm not
gonna argue that but you don't think
it's one out of three people in the
audience are like yeah I don't really
care about birthday I think they're
doing stick yeah I think those people
probably would shed a tear if nobody
said happy birthday on their actual day
okay true thank you true and
statistically how many people's birthday
is it we have 37,000 watching divided
and this is real math divided by 365
right wait no yeah 365 yeah so I think
this makes sense that it's 101 people's
birthdays who are watching right now wow
on average that's crazy that's crazy and
I care about each and every one happy
birthday to the hundred people out there
happy birthday happy
birthday anyway as you were saying that
there's lots of Yes Men on Joe Rogan
here's the ultimate one Brendan shop who
actually what do you guys think about
him Brandon shaber Joo Brandon oh he's a
he's a [__]
[__] he's a meee head I feel like
something happened not too long ago but
I can't recall what it was he was
harassing Bobby Lee they had like a
horrible falling out he was being just a
total [__] mean mean girl but I feel
like he is just going to like always in
some [__] no right yeah I don't really
but anyway um he's the number one most
appeared guest on the show which which
should tell you something because he
literally has nothing to
say he only co-signs everything Joe says
and he keeps inviting him back watch to
[__] kill the [__] out of people t a
chip on your shoulder and a thick skin
the biggest chip on your shoulder and
you also see the drawbacks you see a
huge it is tough to deal with but if
deal with got a a dicey pass in terms of
the law some would say the Diest a rough
reason for why the roughest oh who knows
it's fun it's so it's the funnest yeah
it is fun it's the best me feel like
this is a dirty business like I don't
want to be a part of your dirty business
the dirtiest business God this is a
disaster it's the biggest disaster yeah
it's a good move it's the best dude is
that so [__] wow I love the dice
that's probably why he keeps getting
reinvites though you know just it's easy
for Joe to like hear an echoed version
of
himself that's exactly right that's
exactly right what the [__] is this
video hold on I'm just clicking this was
recommended to me based on Brendan C
probably maybe don't click on it maybe
don't that's Oso he's a cult leader no
yeah he's a cult leader this guy was
also doing like crazy sex crimes right
uh yeah I think so he had like a sex
cult I don't know if it was which one is
I think I've seen the documentary yeah
it's wild wild country I've seen this I
love that documentary so good how did
Google algorithm know to recommend a I
don't know if sha did anything like that
but some of his friends have just don't
some of his friends have you don't know
Brian there's nothing that I've heard
about
shab but anyway here this is I don't
know what this is because democracy
basically
means
government by the
people this could be a good reaction of
the
people for the people
H but the people are
[__] what what a [__] deep
thinker yes yes that's awesome he's so
[Laughter]
15 million views by the
way what yeah 15 million oh my
God what is that uh so we did
Joey uh we have some Jade stuff but we
can say eel too that eel thing is e pit
eel pit I don't know if we time to get
to it I I think we'll have to do the eel
pits some other episode gosh darn it we
just don't have
time time flies when you have fun um I
kind of want to look at this
guy um hold on I'm trying to find my
spot this pickup artist um named
Julian he did something new that came
across me that was funny and then I
realized um that I've seen him before
we've actually talked about him before
M um where the [__] is that cliff
top of show oh here it is oh okay that
what throwing me off he he was doing the
old Gary ve which is suggesting to
imagine murdering everyone you love to
appreciate them did you find by the way
people pay like thousands of dollars to
for this seminar bear that in
mind okay now I want you to Envision
your body just a side note this is
tensing me up it's not relaxing and
adding a smile to my face but
constipate me
more huh I I really don't know how to
get you out of this you
do who do you care about the most in
this world my family who specifically
pick one my brother what's his name Dan
Dan say Dan's on his knees right now
there's a gun to his
head loosen this [__] up where Dan
dies [__] around oh yeah that's a
good way to loosen someone up oh my God
this is like motivational speakership
he's also pick up crazy oh my God that's
horrible advice though just for try to
perform hor and that would make me so
much more stressed yeah not I can't
believe he heard someone give that
suggestion once and he was like M that's
good that's good I'm going to use that
let's see you have one shot I don't want
to see Jew in being all [__] up his ass
constipated I want to see him laughing
to the point point where even if he
tries not to laugh he cannot help but
laugh he's like dude I'm not F it's not
that simple cuz you're dictating the
Rhythm and you're bringing the
Thunder the neckline on that shirt is so
low bringing the Thunder why is this
happening that shirt is really a
nightmare really it is that neckline is
hideous I am not a fashionista but if
you ever run into a guy with a netl neck
line like this run I'm sure of it good
advice up Julian guys help me out
someone to wake up wake up I'm awake I'm
not
sleeping take a [__]
rectangle Julian do you want this H wow
awesome Chad uh wait this is
unironically a trick from Gary ve I
thought you guys were just oh no we
actually did no wa it's real I thought
you were joking no I love Gary ve he's a
[__] weird I link the Gary one in the
descri who do you love the most we
actually we actually had love do this g
v motivation for exclamation mark here
it is I don't recommend it my family
good who in your family pick one all of
them every day make in the in like
literally once a day genuinely sit there
for 5 minutes and make pretend one of
you got shot in the
face different perspectives I'm being
dead serious with you every single day I
actually sit and truly try to convince
myself got shot in the
face there is no [__] way I'm so
sorry there is no not real the biggest
thing I do that leads to the biggest
happiness I have makes happy to imagine
his family being massacred every night
why not just say die why do you have to
shot in the face shot in the face
aggressive oh my god well and then just
to revisit the the results because we
ask love we say let's maybe he knows we
shouldn't make fun let's test it so love
you imagined uh who did you imagine
dying I think my whole family your wait
wait dying or getting shot in the
face everywhere so every night once a
day you would yeah you would go into
your mind and imagine your family being
mastered yeah and this is not a bit I
genuinely did this I genuinely did it no
good no good it leads
to depression I think you didn't feel
good no I did not feel feel very good at
all oh
God that's the first thing I think of
too like I would be so sad every time I
thought of that how is that motivational
listen we we
put dude we give Gary B A lot of [__]
over here and you know what he deserves
it that guy has been winning for too
damn
long wow that's crazy that's a weird one
no good no good this is his current
videos that pisses me the [__] off he
takes a coffee poures cream and it says
say love yourself I was like [__] are
you for real kept sending these cuz he
has a few if you don't love yourself
it's awfully hard to get others to do it
hard [__] wrote on Sharpie on a
glass of coffee it I struggle daily
seeing so many not be gracious to
themselves I tell them imagine your most
loved one was shot in the face I like my
coffee tart wait he did that again no I
was reading the caption I do that in
there
um you know what is this Pinterest girly
things I mean man know your audience
dude what is this where is the other one
maybe you know what would be badass if
he had like a big ass like round fat
steak and then he had a brand that said
be yourself and he went on the meat
right that'd be took it off and it said
be yourself branded on the meat and he
doesn't even wince he says Be
You the [__] I love that it upsets you
so much I agree with you so
[__] the comments are so funny who are
you fooling with this post come
on no one really asks but how are you
bro oh yes you the person reading that
that's a comment or that's what he wrote
respectfully NPC NPC Behavior
respectfully so true true so true but
hey if it makes him happy I'd rather he
do this than tell people to imagine
their loved ones shot in the face true
me personally I would prefer that that's
better and just don't buy it yeah he's a
phony
baloney uh but anyway talking going back
to Julian so uh I was like man I know
who this guy is yeah I think I know he I
remember was in a long time ago he was
in
Japan and he actually got re removed not
just from Japan but he's banned from
entering Australia the United Kingdom
kingdoms and Singapore because he was
basically just sexually assaulting women
on the street you can see a little bit
of it here uh they there's this is just
a compilation I found about
him yeah I remember this one Shy
Guy the music oh this is our music
Australia now the UK this fatties bang
hotties Shir by the way my God and me
this dating
Guru teaches men how to pick up women is
this a motivational guy yes the same guy
and look at the same neckline that's why
the neckline gave it
away and his turnout make girls beg to
sleep with you this is one of his Flyers
after short circuiting their emotional
and logical mind into a million reasons
why they should huh holy crap dude
[Music]
okay it's inspiring here he is in Japan
uh okay whoa yeah it's crazy and he
filmed this and put it all online he
goes if you're in Japan you can
literally do anything to them he said
that he goes I start by just grabbing
them by the neck the [__] Jesus here he
is pushing a girl's head down two of
them oh my God stop he even tweeted
this may as well be a checklist uh to
this power in control coercion and
threats it's the physical violence
sexual exploitation wheel of power and
control this is literally how to essay
yeah use corion threats put together use
uh Al jazer actually weirdly it's from
eight years ago oh no or you mean the
infographic yeah [__] physical
violence sexual I mean Andrew tape
people yeah so so he tweeted this and
said this is a good guide oh my God this
is disgusting it scares me that stuff
like this exists yeah when confronted he
said
look at this he said sh what did he say
he just said he said sh oh here can shut
up bring the audio back you know what
bothers me too if you're gonna be like a
violent misogynistic freak just just own
it but here he is crying on the news out
of context in a way work how could they
be taken out of context give me good use
of Choke a woman he goes it was taken
out of context oh petitions in Canada
Germany and Brazil are getting
signatures to ban him
yeah keep him out of Canada but he go he
travels the world and does seminars and
so he's been banned in Australia United
Kingdoms and Singapore he had uh he had
uh conventions cancelled
there what are we waiting for or he's
probably US citizen yeah okay I guess we
can't ban him well well well we'll work
on that do we have a there's ways do we
have an island we can banish people
to uh the one that Napoleon swam back
from right Zach what was that called
again uh
uh something but I got a I got a new
[__] Island thing I'm referencing now
what does that me uh Lee Harvey Oswald
you swam in the Bay of Pigs oh
apparently that wheel was used for
victims of Domestic and Sexual Assault
to be able to recognize that makes sense
right but then to oh my God co-opt it to
tell people how to be abusive that's
Jesus Christ yeah so this is these are
the these are the leaders of the alpha
male men going their own way whatever
[__] out really sad you know I feel bad
for men who are like so desperate that
they turn to these [__] lunatics
because there's got to be a better we
need a savior yeah how do we yeah I
don't know how to do it because like
they need a hug
honestly true it's true they do need a
hug I mean a lot of times the men that
you see in those seminars like s toally
like normal regular people that should
have no problem like picking up a
girl I don't know what why they feel
just socially awkward people that think
they need to hack their way into getting
a girl to sleep with them yeah anyway so
that was him I just wanted to give an
update on Julian himself who is um out
there
influencing like a warning in an update
himself is he on YouTu heads up he is on
YouTube Julian himself he wasn't banned
yeah I'm surprised he hasn't been banned
let's see what's he been posting
material it's been already even for me
it's just been I'm noticing a crazy
change in in the way that he posted two
days ago oh never run out of things to
say confidence hacks oh my God what are
you
wearing bro the neck still matches what
is happening what the [__] he's wearing
shoes that look like feet what the hell
what is what is the Plaid situation
happening on his pants with that robe I
don't know what the [__] happening my
eyes were just assaulted yeah holy crap
all right let's watch out of things to
say from time to time in conversation
could be with a stranger could be with
even a friend or a family member many
people there so many what the hell what
the [__] what are shoes do what are
those wait what literally what are those
like a costume or something
I I don't know that I can't believe that
this is the real out here maybe he'll
explain no he doesn't explain real I
think this is his
fit ago this is his fit a lot of people
okay hold on it's confidence hacks maybe
he's trying to demonstrate that he can
still be confident while looking like a
[__] idiot what's with this feet
though it might be you know he's trying
to make himself look goofy I mean I I
don't know if this is the case I'm
trying to interpret
what think so no you think this is just
how he rocks it should be most people by
the way years of coaching it's usually
most people you might be better at it
than most but even some they're like you
know I'm sitting with my mother and
suddenly there's an awkward
pause now you might have your go-tos
which are you know the weather's pretty
crazy right what so some rain last night
this
storm it's realizing that yes content is
important even in an event like this
content's important if I were to just be
like blah blah blah blah you'd leave
very
fast but seems cont seem
so I'm feeling the blah blah blah he
sure is yapping I'll tell you that much
they already paid though so true stuck
VI I'm getting it for free yeah is also
important Vibes is everything in a way
Vibe is even more
important so are you this topic which I
call the four layers of communication
mom The Vibes are off right now I'm
going to shift the
conversation he looks like the kid in
class who like chews his shirt
yeah uh let's look at his popular videos
I'm kind of curious what he's up to I
studied social anxiety and thousands of
clients and learned this stop being
needy just has to stop how to actually
be happy how to not be boring 95% of
people hide their confidence stop being
so nice she's afraid
no [__] she's afraid yeah so he recently
came back kind of he's been gone for a
year he tried he's like maybe people
forgot about all that [__] nope he got
out of we're here [__] we ain't forget
he served his time we have not
forgotten if someone were to meet you
they don't know you and they were to ask
themselves huh people hold on that's a
pretty poor showing wait wait wait wa
wait wait wait wait the neckline wait
listen listen is always the
listen to the floor start the video over
again listen to the floor okay in also
where does he get these sh she has it
for every day the people curious why
like like why are you there I just wish
you could find they're just looking for
resources about social anxiety well like
they do better watching an informative
YouTube video or healthy gamer G I
really like his channel theyve no incel
Vibes they've probably tried everything
you know and they just feel
what what were you going to say where
does he get his shirts we're listening
to the floor you don't tell me where he
got his shirts oh no I was just really
curious why that is specifically the
neckline he goes for like does he think
it makes him look muscular maybe he
loves his like deage
area he's about to go strapless he has a
beautiful trying to go sweetheart neckl
W deage this is your like your collar
bones or your de oh I love that I
haven't heard really that word don't
take my word for that I think right no
you're correct oh thank you so much
describes like the top of your chest
like this like the collar bone area and
so when you if like for example uh
somebody were to wear like a skirt
without that's like a cut here strapless
strapless then they would be showing off
their deage
deage wonderful just like our friend
here with deage I love that all right
I'm listening to the floor question I
think you can find these on Amazon you
think he buys it on Amazon yeah it's
awesome anyway I'll find it right now
it's super light fabric too so you can
see his
nipples maybe he's wearing the Kim K bra
yeah all right I'm listening to the
floor Zach I'm
listening if someone were to meet you
they don't know you and they were to ask
themselves huh what would sex with this
person be like huh would they have a
good image in their mind would it be
like oh very passionate or okay I heard
some
squeaking there was specifically one guy
who like dragged his leg
together but in terms of like doing a
paid seminar this is a pretty sad
showing don't you think wait does no one
else think that was the wildest intro
ever it is I want I was listening to the
floor but now I want to go back and
listen to what he actually listen to the
floor but did we hear anything I just
heard a little squeaking right Zach it
was some pretty gnarly squeaking on
headphones you can really hear
it 15 bucks no it's not even a neck it's
like a wide u neck it's called a scoop
neck scoop neck yeah probably a scoop
neck what is a scoop neck it's
this he's like yeah that's
me all right so I'm I got to hear that
again if someone were to meet you they
don't know you and they were to ask
themselves huh what would sex with this
person be like that's
that
[Music]
what huh I I meet someone the first
thing I think about them that's never
been the first thing
gender
Age first thing I think about is what
would sex with them feel like how would
they take being a s know I don't know
that's crazy would they have a good
image in their mind would it be like oh
very passionate or yeah so do like just
like that come on up come on up here
what's your favorite movie do you notice
that
in the first like 10 seconds of this
video it cut to like eight different
cameras he's got a lot of cameras but
they're like all the same angle it's
just like slightly over it was very
strange Dan I don't know if you know
this but more camera angles equals more
important true I have in my long career
online right and as you can tell by our
setup here you've got at least three
that's pretty important wait but you
know including everybody else that's
like eight that's true there's a lot of
camera that's what I'm saying it's kind
of a big deal here the show True any I
feel like he just makes fun of these
people he does which is just annoying me
and like I hate that they're there
you're so right that these seem like
such nice normal people though yeah I
feel like this that probably just want
to learn something I just hope they're
not being misguided you know they are
absolutely being misguided but like yeah
he brought that one guy up in the first
clip and he just humiliated him for no
reason it's
weird um
I'll give you one the Matrix he his
assignment okay now imagine you're
talking to someone try to make them
think about having sex with you so
anyway I was uh laying in bed the other
day and I remembered I had a uh condom
in my top what the [__] have you seen it
yeah okay this guy bringing up the
Matrix within the first 30 seconds too
like can they have Matrix is a fine
movie watch other movie you guys like
all of these pickup artists please it's
their Bible it really is this movie by
two trans women tell us two lines all
about pickup artist about your biggest
takeaway from The Matrix or just the
basic story tell us the story of The
Matrix in a couple lines here but your
goal is add some
purpose okay so the
Matrix was keeping in mind that they're
all thinking what would sex with you be
like
a have Rock bro if I was in a room full
of people that are thinking about
bonting me I would run away I would run
away immediately everybody's looking at
you Jesus all thinking about it is he
just like just so you know I'm thinking
about having sex with you right now wait
that is the exercise though so yeah
that's
awesome them how to be creepy yes he's
literally yeah and also everything needs
to have a sexual ual conation like why
not just use an example like oh these
people are imagining what you're like as
a person or what a friendship with you
would be like you know what would
spending the impression that you're
giving to them why does it have to be in
bed like that's my problem with all
these Alphas is they give them like in
my opinion the exact opposite yeah of
what women would actually want yeah or
at least if you're looking for a
meaningful relationship like the advice
is not like don't ever cry don't ever be
emotional pretend like you're confident
don't be yourself be anyone but yourself
play games don't be authentic around
them just always be thinking about
deprogramming them maybe because people
have been given a certain set of advice
usually and maybe it hasn't worked for
them like oh be yourself or be nice and
so they think oh I have to do the
complete [__] opposite for it to work
but it's like no there's a there's a
balance it could be that's what social
situations help you learn you know I
don't I don't think that there's the
more you think about it I think the
worse off you'll be I think it's just
about confidence in the sense that
you're comfortable in your own skin and
you know just just getting used to being
like hey this is this is who I am and
it's not saying don't ever change don't
ever learn or evolve but it's just
saying like uh you know I'm people like
me gosh darn it and I'm good enough or
what was the phrase and also like
practice makes perfect true it no one is
just like born super social right off
the bat like it's hard but you have to
like put yourself out there bit by bit
you'll see what people respond well to
and what kind of interactions you enjoy
and you live and you learn so
true pop off I wish these people the
best anyway what happened in The Matrix
I'm curious one
thing
so we're trying to [__] you bro get it
together
MH
it was about this guy had there's no
chance for him to win I know he his he
was set up for disaster yes there was
humiliation was is all the only option
here gu who
was who
worked okay yeah yeah all right teach
him something scalea 1 to 10 we're going
to work on this don't worry scalea 1 to
10 how purposeful three two yeah okay so
this here by the way everyone's so
focused on what do I say to be
charismatic what are the words the
stories right you'll even see people
like Analyze This Is by the way there's
dudes like cruising around with handheld
cameras it's wild how document oh W yeah
like different comedians look at how
they say all this if you can't bring the
hump not good bring the hump now this
year is on the low side but guess what
you can also have way too much hump here
in a seminar setting I can come up like
this just give the kid the advice you
know you you you humiliated let's let's
work on it I want to hear a good summary
of The Matrix guess what if I meet
someone on the street I can't be like
hey there every's like ah like that's
way too much okay the same with uh if
you watch my videos on YouTube right
it's like this is
jul this weekend can you wait what
happened you what's one of your favorite
y I don't answer the phone like that
okay this is Julian yes what's one of
your favorite movies Shang Redemption
okay and can you do me one favor yes
this weekend can you please watch The
Matrix oh my
God what dude said you [__] wait is it a
blue pill red pill thing the red pill
boy they love the stop love it their
Bible That's crazy which
again do me a favor bro trans women do
me a favor bro yeah that's awesome Shank
Redemption go what's the story about
bring the P all right imagine that your
wife is murdered and then you are the
one to I was about to say like now keep
don't interrupt him bro he's crushing it
it's sentence yeah give him a break bro
I'm trying to [__] him right now trying
to get it on in my mind with him in mind
what would sex with you be like like
your wife is murdered okay he's
describing the [__] movie you cannot
run around thinking other people are
wondering what sex with me would be like
that sounds like such a bad life it is I
don't think when you talk to like
another person that's what you want like
I don't want to be thinking that when
they're talking to me yeah you think
maybe someone thinks that if you're
involved romantically way down the line
yeah you can't be thinking about that
all the
time here is uh the Matrix uh actually
this is a little no scene from the
second didn't watch that do not take any
pills from this guy and watch your
drink that's actually what Morpheus
said he beamed down instead of Keo and
he said the greatest movie of all time
he said do not trust pills from this man
all right oh
man okay so again what would sex with
you they're all thinking they're all
rating it that's what happened to anyra
he was accused of murdering his wife and
he wasn't even the one that did it he
ended up in prison and he had to figure
out how to make a life for himself there
in prison in spite of the fact that he
wasn't the one who committed the crime
okay he explained that well
mhm good six yeah 5 six
what I agree was good it's a 10 bro I
can't believe he whipped out the
synopsis that quick wow and I was
thinking this guy probably works out he
didn't even stutter started thinking
about what look what's he look like
under the
hoodie what's his hairline
like take the hat
off take St back nice okay now all right
anyway this is the dumbest [__] ever but
that's Julian himself he's trying to
make a come back let's not let that
happen like this program is let's not
let that happen people it's so
simple well that's it we been how long
we've been going there
Dan uh 3 hours 42 minutes holy [__] y
it's 5:00 now felt like nothing yeah
thanks for coming no thanks for having
me I'm really just like a real life
audience member out here that's what it
feels like it's an honor thank you guys
what are you up to lately just playing
valerin and stuff sorry you live uh been
playing some valerant I've been working
on two very special things you guys will
receive it when it launches next month
oo and then hopefully at the end of next
month something else should launch the
next chapter of my life oh I'm very
excited maybe I can come back on the
show around that we can talk some more
about it that'd be great we'll promo it
no matter what we're going to be all
over that whatever it is you guys are
the best TR we're going to plug
the oh I'll give you guys the full the
full rundown next time I'm here okay I'm
so excited to it thank you guys yeah you
guys can catch Pokey obviously on Twitch
primarily and YouTube I think primarily
Instagram whatever Tik Tok I'll be
posting wherever whatever true true true
hopefully you can catch me around here
soon again so catch the most corrupt
person on
Twitch twitch.tv/ pookemon
you want to learn about corruption watch
her play valerant
yes sir and to everybody watching at
home thank you so much we love you on
this so much you Friday
afternoon thank you to uh Rosanna for
calling in as well yeah thanks Ro we
love you have a good weekend and uh well
have a great weekend we'll see you guys
on Monday see you next
time and thank you to our
members
you I can't you're not
there you're not
there
heart I
[Music]
can't
nightm nightm a nightm I
can't there
My head goes my hearts fast it feels
like